.
>>
How to get one meter location
act ritsy
from Android devices
curacy from Android devices.
>>.
>> How to get one meter
location
accuracy from Android devices
>>.
>>
.
Welcome.  Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
>>.
>>
Welcome and thank you for
joining.
Our session will begin soon
.
>>.
>>
Good morning,!  Welcome.
I'm Frank van Diggelen.
>> I'm Roy Want.
>> I'm Weit Wang.
We are all engineers from the
Android team
(Applause.)
>> FRANK VAN DIGGELEN: Thank
you.  We are going to show you
how recent changes in hardware
and standards make one meter
location accuracy possible.
In some cases as soon as this
year.
I will give you a short overview
now
and Roy will introduce and show
you a
live demo and Wei will explain
the WiFi APIs and I will return
and talk about new GPS
technology and APIs.
At the end they will be loading
up for the next session and we
will take questions outside the
door and we will be able for
office hours at 1:30 p.m. today.
It is a great time for location
applications because technology,
hardware, standards and Android
APIs are evolving
simultaneously.
So eventually this means high
accuracy for everybody.  But
today we want to take you under
the hood of location because we
want to
give you the opportunity to get
a head start on the future.
We want to highlight the need to
protect and respect the user.
The more people use location the
more careful me and you have to
be.
We will highlight where you must
get user permissions and we will
close with
guidelines for making great
location apps.  If you think you
have noticed that your phone
seems to be more accurate when
you are inside shopping malls
and office blocks, standard was
a few years ago you are not
imagining it.  With each release
of the fused location provider,
we have had steady improvement
of the Android algorithms and
machine learning for WiFi
locations.  Continues to be
improvement and you will see
indoor accuracy of better than
ten meters of but rount round
type time is the technology that
will take us to the one meter
level.  What about GPS?
Well, in terms of GPS accuracy
in the open sky there has not
been much change in the last few
years of if you are out
in the open sky your GPS
accuracy from your phone is five
meters.
But raw GNSS measurements from
the phones you can now improve
on this and
with changes in satellite and
receiver
hardware improvements can become
dramatic.
Everyone is familiar with the
blue dot.  To get the blue dot,
you get location you need
measurements.  Specifically
range measurements from WiFi
access points or from GPS
satellites.  Today we will show
you how one meter measurement
accuracy is available in phones.
The key technologies are WiFi
round
trip time, GPS dual frequency
and carry phase measurements and
we will show you how to use
accuracy measurements to create
accurate location.  If you just
want to wait a year or two, this
will all find its way in to the
world wide ecosystem and the
fused location provider.  But we
want to give you a chance for a
one to two year lead.
We want to work with you to
accelerate the future.  To take
it and bring it closer to the
present.  So you might wonder
why do I need better location
accuracy anyway?
Well, let's look at two
instances where existing apps
could use much better location
accuracy.  For indoor routing or
navigation of the kind that you
used to in your cars you need
much better accuracy than you
have outdoors.  You need one
meter accuracy because indoor
features like the distance
between cubes or aisles are only
a few meters.
And even for the most loved
outdoor application such as
directions and especially
directions in traffic, we could
use higher accuracy than we have
now.  For example, when you came
here this morning in a car you
probably had the time estimated
by the average traffic speed.
What you really want is the
traffic speed in the lane that
you are in.  So that you could
ask how fast would it be if I
could take the car pool lane.
Of course, many other use cases
and I'll mention a few before we
finish.  But the important thing
is that we will sure that you
will have many more ideas than
we have.  And that's the beauty
of the open Android ecosystem.
So now here's Roy to tell you
about WiFi
rount round trip time.
(Applause.)
>> ROY WANT: Thanks, Frank.
I'm very excited to be here
today to tell you about a new
positioning
technology in Android P we call
WiFi round trip time or RTT.
You will hear me say that
acronym a lot.  Measuring the
time or flight of RF signals.
It has the potential to estimate
your
indoor position to accuracy of
one two to meters.  We are going
to hit the ground running today
before I tell you about the
details of RTT and we are going
to show
you a video of our indoor
navigation
powered by RTT and I want to
emphasize first of a you will
this is not a product but an
internal prototype to explore
the power of technology and how
it can also be used to support
other contextware applications.
This prototype show cases some
of the magic that Google can
offer to its employees today.
We are going to roll the video.
And what you should keep in mind
this
is a bit like car GPS except we
are working indoors.  So in a
moment you see as an application
mapping application and we are
searching for a conference room.
We found that conference room.
It is plotted the route.  And
now we are off.  We are
following the route and as I
make progress you can see the
route is turning gray.  My
position for RTT is the big gray
dot and I am making an error
here.  So the system is
rerouting.  And it is rerouting
again.
I get about 20 feet away it
starts the rerouting process and
I'm following the route and you
can see the code are flying by.
There I am coming in.
And I have arrived at my
destination.  Conference room
Papo.
So that's the power of RTT.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
>> ROY WANT: The thing to
think
about here is that if you didn't
have
one to two meter accuracy then
when that system rerouted it
would jump potentially between
aisles that were
surrounding me and would would
be a terrible user experience.
That's why it is so important to
have this kind of accuracy.  So
before I get in to the details
of
WiFi RTT I want to tell you how
we
calculate indoors now.
We WiFi received signal strength
indication.  And basically we
can calculate distance as a
function of signal strength.
Now the figure that you see on
the left-hand side here the
access point
which is in the center has a
heat map of signal strength.
The green is the strongest.  And
the red is the weakest.
And I have placed two phones on
this diagram at the transition
between the weak and the strong.
Notice that the phone on the
right is
further away from the access
point than the phone on the
left.  So say the signal
strength different distance and
it is this variability in
distance and unfortunately makes
it very
hard to get accurate readings
from RSSI on a regular basis but
there are lots of algorithms and
tricks that we can pull to
improve this but it can be
improved
further and that's where WiFi
RTT comes in to place.
So WiFi RTT, round trip time
uses time of flight.
The time it takes to send a WiFi
RF packet from access point to a
phone and back again and because
where radio
signals travel at the speed as
visible light, if we multiply
the total time of
by speed of light and divide by
2, we get distance and the range
from the phone to the access
point.  So that's the basic
principle.
Now if you want to calculate
position we have to use a
process called
multilateralation.  But the key
thing to think about here the
more ranges you have the more
constraints you have and the
more accurate position you can
achieve and if you can use at
least four ranges then we
think you can get accuracy of
one to two meters in most
buildings.
So why am I telling you about
WiFi RTT today?
Why not last year or before?
2018 is the year of WiFi RTT in
Android.
Your take-aways is are that we
are
releasing our public API in
Android P
based on the IEEE 8211MC
protocol and
furthermore, we are also
integrate ing aspects of this
protoll kol that people use to
put location on a map.
And any time there are RTT
access points in a vicinity, the
accuracy of that position will
be greater.
A little bit of history, the
standard was ratified in 2016,
the end of it and in early 2017
the WiFi
alliance studied during interop
between silicon venders and
that's when we started doing a
lot of work to validate how it
could be integrated in to
Android and by the fall of this
year, of course, we release the
ape so that all of you can have
access to and build your own
applications around that
technology.
So now diving in to the
principles of how WiFi RTT
works.
So the ranging process starts
with a standard WiFi scan.  The
phone discovers the access
points
and based on certain bits which
is set inside the beacons and
the responses we can figure
which of those access points are
RTT capable.  And the phone
chooses one of those to range to
and it starts by making a
request to the access point.
And as a result of the access
point will start a ping pong
protocol back.  The ping is sent
to the phone.  It is called a
fine timing measurement packet.
And the pong is sent back to the
access point is acknowledgement.
The timestamps are recorded at
each end but for the phone to
calculate the
total round trip time it has to
have all those timestamps.  It
sends one more packet which
contains the missing two.
The phone then simply calculates
the round trip time by
subtracting the timestamps from
the AP and its own turnaround
time which are the timestamps
that it recorded.  So that
leaves the time of flight
multiply by the speed of lights
to get distance and we divide by
2 and we get the range that we
care about.  Now it turns out if
you do this process multiple
times you will in fact, get more
accuracy.  So that's what the
protocol allows for.  It allows
for birs.
>> EVE ANDERSS and Android we
are doing bursts of eight of
these events and the system can
calculate statistics.  So the
mean and the variance which
allows to more accuracy plot a
position on a map and knowing
the accuracy also allows us to
calculate a path more accurately
as well.
So now you have ranges.  How do
you get a position.
I want to give your a feel for
how you go about doing this.
There are lots of mathematical
approaches.  I am picking one
because it is easy to explain.
This is where the power of
developers come in to figure out
your own way to do it.  If you
know a phone is a certain range
from an access point that tells
you it
can be anywhere on the
sircircumference of a circle.  I
have written the circular
equation
for that circumference on the
right-hand side.  Now if you
want to find a position you have
got to constrain it.  If you
take four ranges to four
separate access points as I have
shown on the diagram on the
right-hand side you then can see
if those ranges were accurate,
those circles would intersect at
a signal point.
How do you find that point
program mat tickically?
You see the nasty sir
circle equations it is very
straightforward and you pick one
and sub strak and you end up
with a set of Y equations and
those lines are in fact, drawn
on this diagram as well and it
is very easy to find out where
two lines intersect.  One
problem with what I just told
you and the problem is that we
are assuming the measurements
are perfect.
In reality no measurements are
perfect.  Everything has error
and the there will be no exact
solution to that equation.  So
let me give you a more realistic
example.  Here we have several
access points
which we have ranged to and I
have exsaj ger rated the problem
here and you can see some of
those circles don't intersect.
How do you solve that?  You do
the same thing as you did
before.  You sub strak the
circles and you get
the lines but this time they
don't intersect in a point and
your phone lies probably
somewhere maximum likelihood in
the center of of that triangle
and then
we can apply some college math,
squared solution and get a
maximum likelihood.  You can
find standard packages that do
this on the net.  You can refine
this position further by
repeating this process
particularly as the phone moves
and then you can calculate your
trajectory.
So that's basic prinic
principles.
Like any new technology there
are challenges.
We
have experienced some of these
early on.
Robot can measure the range and
validates it against the marks
which are on the floor which
provide us with ground truth.
What we find is that sometimes
is
there a constraint range
calibration offset and sometimes
also you see multi
path effects where the nonsight
path to
the access point to the phone is
actually received rather than
the line of sight path.  That
one can be solved by the vender
using something called a
tentative
diversity but all of these
things are algorithms which the
venders are improving and we
have to go through a teething
process of getting rid of these
bugs.
And Google can help in this
process by
providing reference platforms
and applications to the venders
can calibrate their platforms.
Now I have assumed that you want
to start as an early adopter and
start
using this API but as we move in
to the relatively near future we
expect you to just use the fused
location provider because we are
going to be putting the RTT
capability in to it.  At the
moment fused location provider
uses GPS what is available, cell
signal
strength, WiFi RSSI and also
fuses with
the onboard sensors navigation.
Now we are adding WiFi RTT in to
that mix and it will increase
the accuracy whatever RTT access
points are available.  Okay.  So
the one other thing to remember
is that when you are doing
itself you had to know the
position of the access points.
We have a fused location
provider we will know those
positions automatically for you.
We will crowdsource those
positions so you won't have to
worry about that and that will
make life a lot more -- a lot
easier for you to write
applications.  Okay.  So now we
are going to take it up a notch
and we are going to give you a
life RTT demo in collaboration
with some of our colleagues in
geo.
So what I have over here on
podium is a phone.  Bring it
back.  Okay.  There we go.
Which is running an RTT system
in combination with Google
mobile maps.  And what we are do
something we are using a number
of access points which are
around the room.
I'm -- you saw the blue boxes
which are on slides.  You can
see them around the room towards
the back on this side and also a
couple in the center over here.
Now we will take to bear in
mind, this phone because we are
in a tent would normally receive
GPS signals.
You are only using RTT with this
phone
and what I am going to do I'm
going to walk around the aisles
and I have already got a plot.
So I'm going to start moving
now.  It is not going towards
the corner of the stage and you
should see the blue
dot with my man inside following
me.
And we, of course, we expect
accuracy of one to two meters.
So I am walking on the aisle.
The aisle here is about two
meters
across thereabouts and it is
nicely
following within that accuracy.
I think the demo environment has
been very good to us so far.
So we are going
along a little bit of lag, and
we are approaching the turn
around point where
I am going to walk up the aisle
and rerouting as I come back to
make my path a little bit
shorter.  And you can see we are
going very
nicely and still well within the
one to
two meters and if you had GPS
shown here as well and you would
be expecting to
see five meters, but that
outdoors.  Indoors in a typical
building you are only going to
have indoor location technology
such as this.
I'm approaching the corner of
the
stage and at this point I'll
hand back over to Wei.
(Applause.)
>> ROY WANT: Thank you very
much.
Wang Wei is going to tell you
about the details of the API.
>> WEI WANG: Hey. Thanks
Roy.  What a great demo.
So now you must be very eager to
try it yourself.
Let me walk you through the RTT
see how you can add RTT in your
own application.
So as Roy mentioned RTT measures
the
round trip time between two WiFi
devices.
So both mobile phone and exit
points need to support 8.211
protocol.  RTT can give you very
fine location down to one meter
accuracy.
So your application needs to
declare access find location
permission.  And, of course,
both locations and WiFi scan
need to be enabled on the mobile
device.
Okay.  So how do you know
whether your mobile phone
supports RTT?
In P we added a new system
feature called feature WiFi RTT.
So you can simply check whether
this
is true on a mobile device or
pixel
phones running 2 and above will
support RTT.  How do you know
whether your access points
support RTT?
As normal you will need to do a
WiFi
scan and get a list of WiFi scan
routes.
Least -- WiFi scan routes and
check whether this method is
802.11.  This will tell you
whether the access
points support RTT.
So after you get a list of RTT
enabled
ATs simply add them to scan,
request builder to build a scan
request.
RTT is done by WiFi RTT manager
which you can get by getting the
system
service WiFi RTT rendering
service.  Okay.
Now I am ready to start RTT
rendering
of by sending the RT request to
the RTT
manager, RTT will start.
RTT takes no more than 100
milliseconds and when finished
you will
get a list of information, you
including the status that RTT
might fail.  And also the most
importantly the distance between
the mobile phone and the access
point.
So here is the list of
information you can get from
RTT.
You get the distance, also get
the distance and information
which is
(inaudible) from renderings in
multiple FTMs and you can also
get number of
attempted FTM measurements and
number of settlement amendments.
So ratio of measurements will
give you idea of how good the
WiFi environment is for RTT
rendering.
Okay.
So I mentioned all pixel devices
will support RTT.  How about
access points?
We are begin access points
supporting MCC protocol in
production and are excited to
let you know Google WiFi will
soon support MC11 protocol.
Yeah.  Thank you.
(Applause.
)
>> WEI WANG: By the end of
this year
WiFi will have RTT enabled by
default.
World wide we are beginning to
send the deployment.
Is leading the deployment.  Of
course, this is just the
beginning of the long journey.
We are eager to send a larger
penetration rate of RTT in up
coming years.  I am going to
hand over to Frank to talk about
one meter GPS.
>> FRANK VAN DIGGELEN: Thank
you.
(Applause.)
>> FRANK VAN DIGGELEN: Okay.
So let's move to the great
outdoors
and speak about G PS.  I am
going to show you just enough to
explain what's new to the
satellites and what's new in the
phones.  And how you can exploit
these changes
to get better location accuracy
from GPS
when you are outdoors under open
sky.
So GPS works like this, it sends
a code
from the satellite and the code
encodes the time at the
satellite.  The net travels to
you through space
and arrives at you and your GPS
receivable will compare that
time with the time in clock.
Difference between those two
tells how far you are away.  It
is kind of like you have a tape
measure where one ends at the
satellite and you are holding
the spool.  At any moment you
can look down and read a number
which is the difference in these
two times.  If you move further
away, you read a bigger number.
You move aa little bit closer
you read a smaller number.
But now the actual GPS tape me
sure is special.  It is really
long.
Secondly the tick marks occur
only
every 300 meters because shes
these bits
of a code occur at a rate of one
microsecond.  So this is like a
tape measure where instead of
having all these inches on
here you only have a mark every
meters and it brerP Poe lates
between
those marks and there is our
five meter accuracy.
Because how does that code get
through space in the first
place.  It is carried on a
carrier wave.
Radio wave for GPS has a
wavelength that is less than 20
centimeters.  And your GPS
receiver can measure where you
are on this wave and as long as
it keeps tracking it, can
measure
relative motion with great
precision.
And this is because the receiver
will measure the phase and as
you move that phase will change.
But now what about getting your
absolute location?
The trouble with the carrier
phase ruler if you like is that
it is -- it is
kind of like a ruler with very
precise markings on it but no
numbers at all.  So your
receiver can tell you the phase
of the wave you are on but it
doesn't know are you the green
dot, or the red dot.  So how do
you solve that problem?  Well,
for that you need to introduce a
new concept, which is GPS
reference stations.
So these are GPS receivers at
fixed sites measuring the same
thing at the same time.
They communicate that data to
you with
well-known algorithms.  You can
work out where you are relative
to the reference station with
great precision, with this
carrier phase precision.  You
know where you are with great
precision.  So this concept is
not new.  This is being in
commercial GPS
receivers since the 1980s for
surveying.  Hence our little
surveyor there
holding the GPS antenna on the
stick.  The availability of
these carrier phase measurements
from phones.
And dual frequency measurements
in phones.
Right now all of your
Smartphones all
Smartphones everywhere have GPS
or GNSS on one frequency band
only.  It is known as L1.  But
there is a new frequency in
town.  It is called L5 and it is
supported by all these GNSS
systems.
GPS, Galeo and IRNSS and the
availabilities of a second
frequency means that you get
much faster convergence to
carrier phase accuracy if
you are did doing this kind of
procedure.  We went through the
ambiguity that you have on a
single wave.  Now look at what
happens if you introduce a
second wave at a different
frequency.
Immediately you can disam big
ways because you could not have
that same phrase on that second
wave as on both of those
wavelengths.
You could not be on the red dot
if you
are at the peak of the red wave.
You can get much faster
convergence to the very high
accuracy that you want.
All right.  So what about
hardware?  Well, in the last few
months several
companies that produce consumer
PS chips have announced the
availability of dual
frequency L1L5GPS chips both for
the automobile market and phone
market and these chips are
designed in to cars and
phones.  Now let's talk about
the measurements themselves and
the APIs.
The phone must support the GNSS
measurements API.
And your app is going to need
access fine location permission
and location needs to be on.
So this is the basic
requirements.  So how do you
know if a particular phone
supports these measurements?  At
a high level you can go to a
website that we maintain G.
code part of the Android
developer site and this is just
a table there that
lists phones that support the
GNS's measurements and also
which characteristics they
support.  So it will tell you
which phones support the me
surements and which support the
carrier phase measurements.  You
do the this as follows:  You
need a method on status changed
and it will
return an integer that tells you
the capability of the phone.
Either if the phone just does
not support the measurements at
all or if they are supported but
location is off, or if they
support it and location is on.
And the last case you are good
to go.
So let's get in to details of
APIs.
There is get con stelation type
which
tells you which of different
GNSS con
stelation, get carrier frequency
Hertz.
And then most importantly there
is get accumulated Delta range
meters which is
how far along that wave the
receiver has tracked you since
it began tracking the signal.
Then there is something else I
need to explain which is duty
cycling.  When you are
navigating with the phone and
you see the blue dot when you
are moving along, you might
think that the GPS is on the
continuously and it is actually
not.
What's happening in the phone is
that GPS will by default be on
for a fraction of a second and
then off for the remaining
fracturesing fraction of a
second and then repeat.  This is
to save battery.
You perceive that the GPS is on
all the time but it is duty
cycling internally.  Now for the
carrier phase processing
you have to continually track
because the carrier wave is the
ruler with no numbers on it.
If the GPS was on and your
receiver measured the phase.
You would start processing if
the GPS then goes off for a
fraction of a second, now you
have lost where you were.  It
will start again.
You will re akwir and you will
never solve the problem.  Right?
You need the tape measure to
stay out and you need to process
and you need to disable duty
cycling and you can do that in
Android P with a developer
option.  Which I will talk some
more about in a minute.  What I
have shown on the right is a
screen shot of an application
that we have put out.
It is called GNSS logger and
this enablings you to log the
rule measurements in the phone.
Nice thing about this app it is
a reference app.  The code is
open sourced and available to
you on github.
So when you build your app
please make use of our code.
And when you do build an app
that
needs raw measurement you will
need the
Android location manager API
with measurements of and this
method requires to you pass a
GNSS measurements call
back shown here.  You construct
this call back and
override the method and unstatus
changed
and that will gir you the
integer status to discuss.  If
they are you then override the
method on GNSS measurements
received and
this allows you to receive a
GNSS event, for example, every
second and this event gives you
the values that we have been
talking about.
Con stelation type and
accumulated
Delta range
.  For duty cycling that's a
developer option.  You access
that through the developer page
on your phone as you see there
on P.
And this allows you to disable
the duty cycle.  Now keep in
mind this dueses a tradeoff
between getting the continuous
measurements and battery life.
There will be an impact on
battery life.  How much?
Even when GPS is on continually
it will use less than 20% of the
power that screen on users.  So
that gives you a feel for the
magnitude.  Now this is a
developer option
precisely because it is a
tradeoff in battery life and we
are very concerned about
maximizing battery life.  But if
you and we together can prove
that there is value in this
option if
people want it then it will be
upgraded to a fully supported
API in the future.  Here is a
block diagram that shows the
basic architecture that we
expect if you implement an app
for high accuracy.
You got the GPS and GNSS chip.
GNSS's measurements come up
through the APIs that we
described and your app live Is
at the top in the application
layer.  You are going to need
access to a
reference network to get the
data that the reference stations
are tracking.
There are publicly available
reference networks.  I have
listed one down at the bottom.
IGS.
org and you can get data from
them free.  And you need to
process that data in some kind
of position library and that
does all carrier phase
processing and that is available
for
code.  And then you are good to
go.  Now I mention that dual
frequency gives you much faster
convergence to the high
accuracy.  But you don't have to
wait until the dual frequent ri
phones come out.  You can start
doing this with single frequency
phones and here is is an example
of someone who has already done
this.  This an app created by
the French
space agency and they are doing
exactly what we show on the
block diagram on the left and
they are achieving submeter
accuracy after a few minutes of
convergence.  Here is some more
external analysis that's been
done in a similar way.  This is
from a paper called positioning
with Android GNSS.  This is
using one of those chips that I
showed you.  The chip that goes
in cell phones that does dual
frequency and what has been
shown here is the cumulative
results of many different starts
of the GPS and what you see is
that most of the time the
accuracy is better than a meter.
You see that on the vertical
access
which is 0 to 1 meters and it
gets to
better than one meter in less
than a minute.  As long as the
phone continues to
track that carrier phase
continuously.  Here is another
similar but different paper.
This is using one of the chips
that's meant for cars.  So this
was tested in a car.  Driving
around that track there and
what the plot here is showing is
the accuracy after the initial
convergence while the car was
driving.
You see with GNSS alone the
accuracy
was one to two meters and with
this
carrier phrase processing it is
at a
couple of centimeters.  Of
course, you need the device
location to be enabled and your
app has to have location
permission.  So that's going to
come from the user.  You need
the basic GNSS measurements.
That's been available since
Android N.
You also need this continuous
carrier phase I have been
talking about and that's
available in P with a developer
option and it would be nice too
have dual frequency for fast
convergence.
You need a reference network
such as the one that I already
mentioned.  There are commercial
reference networks out there and
commercially available software
to do the same thing.  But I
recommend you start with the
free stuff and go from there.
And then finally there is the
app from you.  So in summary
everything we have been
showing you here we have indoor
and outdoor technology that
that's been evolving kind of in
parallel.
In each case we have a new
technology
in and Android P gives you
something to access.
WiFi round trip time and round
trip time enabled access point.
We give you public API to access
measurements.  So this is where
some of you can do this this
year because if you have a
customer who owns or controls a
venue, they can upgrade their
access points.  Sometimes just a
firmer upgrade and then you have
the infrastructure Android P
comes out later this year and
you can implement something like
what Roy just demoed and have
indoor navigation or many other
apps.  For example, someone goes
in to store, where is the milk.
You can make the world a better
place
for all of us by saving us from
the
terny of have to ask directions
from strangers.
(Applause.
)
>> FRANK VAN DIGGELEN: And
if you -- if you not one of
those people who has access to
this now in a few years the
infrastructure will naturally
evolve as access points upgrade
to round trip time and this will
be available from fused location
provider as Roy said.  Now
outdoors, okay for the this
carrier phase process it is not
just outdoors but outdoors with
open of sky and what you need?
Dual frequency and continuous
carrier
phase and we give you the ooich
API and developer option to make
use of that.  And then
application -- what can you do
outdoors with open sky?  We
already mentioned the traffic
example and theror many other
examples
that come to mind where existing
GPS accuracy doesn't cut it.
Geo caching where people go to
look for treasures.
Precision sports monitoring,
five meters not good enough.
One meter would be great.
Speaking of sports more and more
drone apps where you follow me
and the drone will follow along
and videos you.
It would be nice if it vid yoes
you and not the person next
door.  There are hundreds of
apps we want you to do that.
And you and I us bend the arc of
history.
I am looking forward to seeing
you here next year.  I want to
leave you with a couple of
pointers when you build location
apps,
build great location apps you
must have user trust.
Provide them with user
transparency and control.  You
have to ask for location
permissions and explain what you
are doing and how it benefits
them.
When things go wrong, make your
app recover gracefully.  If
measurements are unavailable for
some moment or something goes
wrong you can fall back to used
location provider location.  And
finally respect the battery life
tradeoffs that we have
discussed.  So I must remind you
to fill out your
surveys, please at that site.
And as I mentioned we will be
available outside the door here
for any questions.  So from all
three of us thank you.
(Applause.
)
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand ambassadors will assist
with
directing you through the
designated exits.  If you are
registered for the next
session in this room we ask that
you clear the room and return
via the registration line
outside.
Thank you
.
>>.
>>
Pave the way to start using
Firebase at work
>>.
>>
.
Welcome.
Please fill in the seats in the
front of the room.  Thank you.
>>.
>>
Welcome.  Thank you for joining.
Our session will begin soon. T
>>.
>>
Good morning.  Thanks for coming
out early this morning.
My name is John Shriver-Blake ab
I'm a product manager on
Firebase.  I am going to be
joined later today by Mike
McDonald.  And we are here to
talk about using Firebase at
work.
You see, lots of people know
that Firebase is a great way to
build great apps.  You can use
products like cloud Firestore
and cloud functions to build
scaleable apps quickly.  You can
use products like crashlytics
and performance monitoring so
understand and improve your
app's quality.  And you can use
products like Google analytics
for Firebase and Firebase
predictions to understand and
grow your user.
r base.  Unfortunately too many
people think that Firebase isn't
ready for work.  Particularly
at-large organizations.  I get
questions all the time about
security, compliance and
production readiness.  And so
today we are going to answer
some of those questions and arm
you with the information that
you need to use Firebase at
work.
We are going to specifically
cover these three areas.  Is
Firebase ready for my
organization?
Can I manage and secure my
resources in the way that I want
to?  Is Firebase ready for my
lawyers?
Can it meet my compliance and
regulatory requirements?  Is
Firebase ready for production?
Can I achieve production scale
and monitoring with Firebase?
We are going to answer these
questions today.
So let's take the first
question.  Is Firebase ready for
my organization?
Specifically can you control
access to Firebase resources and
enforce organizational policies?
The answer is yes.
Firebase developers have access
to the same powerful Google
Cloud Platform
tools to secure and access the
resources in Firebase.
Which is great.  Right?  And
this works because when it comes
right down to it, Firebase
projects are cloud projects.
And while we provide a simple
and intuitive UI to help people
onboard with
the platform, it is all built on
top of Google cloud
infrastructure.  So those who
need the power can use the
Google Cloud Platform tools to
manage their Firebase projects.
Now when it comes to managing
and securing access to our
projects, there are a few core
cloud tools that you need to be
aware of.  First is cloud
resource manager.  Which allows
you to centrally manage all of
the projects in your
organization.
It allows an administrator to
get visibility in to every
project they have
and organize those projects in
to a hierarchy of folders.
Second, is cloud identity.
Which provides centralized
identity administration for
orgs.  It includes the ability
to support single sign on and
enforce two factor
authentication.  Now many of you
are probably using G suite which
offers many of the same features
and also works with Google cloud
and Firebase.
Finally, there is cloud IAM.
Cloud IAM gives you fine grain
control.
Allow us to do this about I
assigning roles.
For instance, there is a role
called
app engine viewer.
On the other hand, you might
gave an
edit role for a smaller set of
people who need it.  If the
predefined roles are not for
you.
You can define custom roles.
Finally I will e mention that
all permission are logged and we
give you a full audit log of
what was changed when and by
who.  Now those of you who are
familiar with Firebase, probably
know that today Firebase does
not support fine grain roles or
permissions which limits your
options for controlling access.
Well, today we begin the rollout
of fine grain permissions for
Firebase.  We have defined a set
of permissions like stability
admin and developer viewer that
allow you to grant access to a
limited subset of Firebase.  In
addition we are going to give
you access to fine grain
permissions.  So you can define
exactly the roles that make the
most sense for you.  Now we just
started rolling this out today.
And it may take a few weeks
before you see it in your
project.  But I am going to give
you a demo.  Switch over to the
screen, please.  Okay.  So here
I am logged in to the Firebase
console as myself and I want to
give Mike access to this
project.  So I'm going to go to
project settings, users and
permissions.
And this loads up a custom
Firebase UI that makes it easy
for most Firebase users to add
users to their Firebase project.
Let me go ahead and add a
member.
We will include Mike.  Okay.
And now I need to pick a role
for Mike.  When I click on the
roll drop yun we support the
same project level roles that
Firebase has always supported
but we can assign custom access
to Firebase.
I only need Mike to send
notifications
and who worry a T-shirt and a
hoodie for today's talk.
I am doubting his
professionalism.  I am only
going to give him access to grow
and not our developer products.
Save that.  And switch over to
Mike.  So you can see on this
window I am logged in as Mike.
I am in the same project and
because
Mike has access to grow admin,
if I go
to -- uh-huh.  Okay.  Let's do
this.
If I go to Cloud Messaging with
Mike's
account, he has full read write
access to view and sent
notifications.  If I go to the
develop section, and I
try and get in the database I
get access denied.  I know that
Mike is not mucking around in my
data.  Some of you are probably
thinking that you need more fine
grain permissions for your
organization and we got that
covered, too with fine grain
permissions and custom roles.
Going back to my UI I am back in
the
Firebase UI for IAM and roles
are not in this UI.  They are
considered an advanced scenario.
So I'm going to go over to
advanced permission settings and
what this is going to do is open
up the cloud IAM console.  So
these systems are working on the
same Backends, same users, same
permissions but the cloud
console has a much broader array
of features to help you control
and manage access to your
project.  One of those features
are roles.  So I'm going to go
ahead and click in to roles and
you can see here the full
list of roles that are
predefined for my project and
also a role I created up here
called Mike's special role that
has specific permissions just
for Mike.  Now you probably
wouldn't make a specific role
for one person.  But you get the
gist.  You get the choice to
define the roles the way you
want with the permissions that
you want.
Finally I mentioned audit
logging.  And we do offer quite
a bit of audit logging for these
scenarios.  I will go back to
the Cloud Platform
console, dashboard and another
tab called activity and this
activity feed gives you a
detailed rundown of
administration action in your
organizations.
And so you can see there is a
record for that last change that
I made.
Firebase John@Gmail removed
Firebase admin from Firebase
Mike.  That's interesting.
That's why they didn't work.
Anyway you get the full view of
everything that's happened in
your organization so that your
administrators can really keep
an eye on what's happening.  So
can we go back to the slide,
please?
So a take away for you is that
Firebase is ready for your
organization.
You can use cloud powerful
manager tools to manage your
Firebase projects and restrict
access.  Let's talk about the
lawyers.  If you have ever tried
to deploy a new service in a
large organization you know
it can be a real challenge.  Add
to the complexity of GDPR and
the whole thing is really
daunting.  We want to make sh as
easy as possible for you.  And
to this end the Firebase team
has
been investing a lot in
compliance and today we are
ready to meet many organizations
compliance needs.  In addition
we have been particularly
focused on how we can help you
implement privacy best practices
and be compliant with GDPR.  Now
before I go much further I want
to make this clear, I am not a
lawyer and this is not legal
advice.  And we are going to
talk about general best
practices but really every case
is different.  So if you haven't
had a conversation about these
topics with a lawyer, I strongly
suggest that you do.  Okay.  So
I had a funny experience this
winter.  I was at an indoor
water park with my son.  And we
were waiting to get if n line
and a couple mind me also worked
together started talking about
GDPR in line at a water park and
they were really stressed out.
They were talking about how much
work they had do, how many open
questions they had and how hard
it was to get a clear answer to
those questions.
And I really could not figure
out why they were talking about
GDPR at a water park.
It was only later that I
realized that I was wearing this
GDPR T-shirt.  It was my fault.
My choice of T-shirt that
day ruined that couple's
vacation.  It has been a lot of
work and a fair amount of
stress.
But with the benefit of
hindsight I have come to view it
as an opportunity of it is an
opportunity to ensure that you
are doing the right things where
users and privacy.
So we are going to discuss today
our privacy best practices and
how Firebase can help you
achieve them.  Now there is
really a lot to consider with
privacy.  But I want to call
your attention to these three
areas that I think require
specific focus.
So one, how can you ensure that
the third parties that you rely
on are doing the right thing
with your user's data.
Two, are you properly handling
notice and consent from your
users.  Three, are you following
best practices around
transparency and control of user
data.  Let's dig in to No.
1, today it is almost impossible
to
build an app without rely ing on
third party service.
Now if those services have
access to your user data, it is
really important that you have a
clear understanding of how that
data is used, and protected by
those services.  You also need
to ensure that use is consistent
with your own terms of service,
privacy policy and consent
experiences.  So you really need
to understand this well.  So how
can Firebase help?
First in order to for to help
you be confident in our security
and privacy
practices we have really made a
lot of progress on getting
certifications for Firebase.
You can see we have beviy of ISO
and Sox certifications and we
have been
adding certifications over the
last several months.
We added ISO2017 and ISO2018 to
Firestore and we are going to
continue to make progress on
those specific certifications
over the next couple of months.
Okay.  One other thing I want to
highlight in this area o DPSTs.
They are legal agreements
between you and your third party
service provider
that govern how your data is
protected and used by those
services.
If you are subject to GDPR you
need to have these types of
agreements in place with your
service providers.  The good
news is that Firebase makes this
really easy.  All of Firebase
services are covered
under a GPST and included by
default in our terms of service.
So if you are using Firebase and
you have accepted our most
recent terms you
are covered under our GPSTs.
Okay.
Let's talk about notice and
consent.  I brought this up
because notice and consent
standards are really changing.
And so if you haven't reviewed
your notice and content flows
recently I strongly suggest that
you do that.
The high level goal here is to
make it really clear to users
what data you are collecting and
how that data is used.  If you
do need to get consent, you need
to really focus in on that
scenario and make sure that you
are getting consent in an
explicit and clear way from the
users.  Also and this is
something that people often
miss, if you need consent, you
need to make sure you are not
gathering data before you get
that consent.  This one trips a
lot of people up.  Finally, you
need to make sure that consent
is recorded properly and that
you can prove that you have it
if you need to.  We have been
working hard to help our users
and our developers with notice
and consent.  First we have a
number of products today that
auto initialize on launch.  And
therefore may start collecting
data immediately from your
users.  You may decide that you
need consent for that data.  So
to give you the flexibility that
you need, we have updated all of
these APIs so they can be
configured to not auto
initialize.  So you can get the
user consent that you need and
then go ahead and
initialize those SDKs.
In addition we have launched an
update
to friendly picks that
demonstrate how to treak user
consent using Firebase.
It is an open source demo
application built on the
Firebase platform and
includes iOS and Android.  We
hope that you will take a look
at it and it makes it easier for
you to implement this critical
user experience.  Okay.  Finally
let's talk about transparency
and control.  The basic
principle in this area is that
it should be easy for your users
to understand what data you have
about them and they should be in
control of that data.  So a
great example of this is
Google's my activity site.  It
shows you user as detailed view
of
all of their data on Chrome,
Android and Google search as
well as other Google products.
It is quite an exhaustive set of
data and provides a lot of
transparency for our users.  It
also puts users in kroechlt they
can delete pieces of data or
delete data in bulk.  Think it
is a really great example of how
to implement transparency and
control for your products.  We
want to help Firebase developers
implement best practices in this
area.  And update that we made
recently was improving our
support for deletion in a number
of our services.  Particularly
services like crashlytics and
Analytics.  It is now possible
in all of these services to
delete data for a single user.
So if you get a request to
delete data you are now
empowered to do that.
We have also launched a deletion
and export guide.
It walk through the process
cess of iment pleming user
deletion and
export flow es.
s.  Now before we jump in to the
code I
want to mention that this code
is publiclible available on
github.  You can grab it today.
It also covers user initiated
export which is another key user
scenario for data control.  The
code itself starts out with this
function.  That's responsible
for initiating the delete.  The
really great thing about cloud
functions is the amount of
flexibility
that gives you and how you
trigger that function.  We are
taking advantage of the fact
that Firebase off is an event
emitter.  This functional
trigger when off.
user on delete gets called.  So
the basic model here you delete
the Firebase.  This function
kicks off and deletes the rest
of their data.  It gives you a
lot of flexibility in this area.
So you can also trigger this off
of an
htpq or using the client side
SDK.
Once triggered the code goes
through and has wipe out calls.
Skipping down a bit, this is the
database wipeout function.  You
will see in the top reading in a
list of paths and then we are
iterating through each one of
those paths and removing them
from the database.  But where
dot paths come from?
They are near user privacy.JSON.
In this case it is a path called
users
and another called admins.
So we are only deleting data for
this specific user.  Other
products work in a similar way.
So there is an example for
storage
here below that will delete
storage data for that particular
user.  So that's it.  If a few
lines of code we are properly
cleaning up our data when a
Firebase user gets deleted.
So the key take away for you is
that Firebase is ready to meet
most organizations's compliance
needs and we have provided a
number of tools to help you
implement privacy best practices
and be compliant with GDPR.  Now
I am going to hand over to Mike
to
talk about taking your Firebase
product to production.
>> MIKE MCDONALD: Thanks.
So John convinced your manager,
their manager their manager's
manager, all of
those pesky compliance officers
in your org and your legal team.
But now you are to come back to
your team and convince your
operations and DevOps folks that
Firebase is ready to scale.
Luckily Firebase is built on top
of Google Cloud.
It can be built to scale the
largest needs of customers
without breaking the bank.
Firebase is built on top of
Cloud
Platform, specifically actually
on top
of a couple of Google Cloud.  So
the same underlying database.
And that provides the
scalability that you need to
start building on Firebase and
scale in to Google Cloud.
But scalability is nothing
without reliability.  Firebase
offers 99.
9 and 99.
5SLAs on products.  That's what
we promised.  People often see a
lot better.  So we are looking
at a chart right now
provided by Gartner.
They are an industry analyst
that is measuring uptime.  This
is storage bucket.  For
instance, Google Cloud storage
on
GCP.  Con teshgs, 99.9% SLA is
nine hours of downtime.  That's
540 minutes.  Over there in blue
so that's Google Cloud, that's
22 minutes of downtime which is
99.995.
So that's 4 and a half 9s of
uptimetime observed over the
year.  It is literally query a
bucket a couple times a second
for a year.
This is a third party industry
analyst.
We also understand that
sometimes you
need to create resource in
particular locations.  You want
to serve content directly from
where your customers are or you
need to comply with legal
regulations with various
countries.  They offer 15
different regions around
the world and we have anounsed
four additional regions which
are those white
dot
dots that are coming zoning
online.  I want to say I want to
create this new bucket and you
can select the region and you
can see a number of multi
regional and regional
deployments and you can select
what type of bucket you want and
then create it in Firebase.
In the near future we expect
that cloud
functions and Firestore will
also offer this capability.
So now that we are comfortable
creating resources and we know
that they are scale, we need to
verify that the
code that John wrote does what
it says it does.
To do this we will use
Stackdriver.  So Stackdriver
provides visibility in to your
production resources for the
entirety of Cloud Platform and
parts of Firebase.  It does
logging, monitoring alerts and
things like tracing debugging
and performance profiling of
here is a quick reference of
what Firebase services support
which of those various stack
driver integrations.  We will
dye in to how each of them work.
So earlier John showed code that
was deployed on the cloud
function.  We need to ensure
that those wipeout
functions are running and not
erroring out.
It integrates nicely with
Stackdriver logging.
As you can see this is actually
the friendly picks production
Backend logs.  So we can see
cleanup account,
moderate posts, send follower
note,ifications and we can every
time a function execute
execution started as well as all
the logs from standard error and
standard log of we automatically
suck those up.  So you don't
have to write anything special
in your code.
You can just say standard sh
console.
log in JavaScript and it will
log it.  Or if something errors
we will pull it out and display
T.
That's a great view.  But what
happens if you want more
proactive error reporting.  So
you can use Stackdriver error
reporting to understand there a
new error.  Here is exactly
what's wrong.  John's code may
have been error free but that's
not true for everything that we
are running right now.
We can see up at the top a bunch
of open alerts that have been
opened
because our code has thrown an
error.  You can see that top one
says deletion
of inactive user failed error
and internal error occurred.
Quota exceeded.  It tells us
what the problem is and how we
can resolve that in the Google
cloud console and tells us how
many occurrences of error
occurred and when they happened
and when the last one was
and I get e-mails for every
single error
that occurs in friendly picks.
It is really nice.  Now we want
to build dashboards to
understand how things are
working in production.
Stackdriver provides logging or
monitoring and alerting with a
bunch of different metrics about
each of these Firebase and
Google cloud services.
So you can create real ly
granular dashboards.  Slide sin
tended to be a little
overwhelming to show you how
much information we are giving.
The realtime database spits out
20 or 25 different metrics.
Using the Stackdriver console it
is
really easy to create custom
dashboards and in the demo that
I will show we will
go in to greater detail and im I
will I will make a new
dashboard.  How much data is
stored in cloud
storage and send setting alert,
send me an e-mail.
You can configure those again
those alerts in the Stackdriver
console.
So on the left side we are
saying any time a metric goes
above that large number which
happens to be five gigabytes any
time that threshold is
exceeded, send an I alert to
Firebase
Mike@Gmail com.  Maybe your
company stores everything in a
Wiki or other mark down you can
copy that in and this will get
sent along in the alert.  So you
can actually debug immediately
once you get that alert.  On the
right I have set up a bunch of
different alerts.  You can do
some really simple things that
are just basic conditions that
say
hey, if this metric is over five
gigabytes for more than a minute
or this metric no longer exists
send me an alert
and you can do more complicated
things
like velocity alert.  That's
sending mooey information that
says hey I just got this huge
load spike.  Maybe I need to do
something or hey the number of
objects stored in my storage
bucket has doubled.
Maybe I want to start
eliminating old data.  This is
what one of those alerts look
like when it fires.  So I run a
couple of production services.
One of them, for instance, I run
a Minecraft server and I got an
e-mail saying my server is down.
What do I do and as you can see
I have documentation that says
is the have, M up.  SSH in to
the VM and make sure that
the disk are mounted and make is
your
that my system D job is working
perfectly.  It works for various
other Cloud Platform services
that I mentioned.  And then once
you acknowledge it you
get another e-mail ma says the
incident is over and everything
is fine.
We have pager duty and other
tools like slack integrations
that you can
send them to wherever is most
convenient for or your org.  So
we built our app.  Running in
production and can scale.  We
have great visibility.
Everything is going fine and you
are
sitting in your desk one day and
one who
looks like John walks over and
says how much does this cost.
I need to report to my VP.  And
you are sweating bullets.  You
go to the Cloud Platform website
and we have this awesome pricing
calculator.  So on both Firebase
and Google
platform you can dial around and
say hey
based on the information I have
in stack
driver it is projecting that I
am going
at X gigabytes of data store a
month and the Cloud Platform
pricing calculator you can start
tweaking things like I I want to
move this data to a cheaper
storage class of it is not being
accessed as frequently.
That's going to be cheaper for
you.  And similar to Stackdriver
we have
kind of the estimation portion
and you can set up billing
alerts on top of that.
Maybe you budget $1,000 a month
for storage costs.  You can set
iP a budget that will send you a
billing alert when you have
exceeded that.  It is really
nifty.  Let's actually see that.
Switching over to the demo, we
are going to go through all of
those things just so that you
believe me.  Okay.
Here we are in the
Google Cloud console.  You can
see this massive scrolling
things.
It is not just cloud function.
Can show up in here and I can
get certain methods.
I can get all of the Google
Cloud project things and you can
see when service accounts were
used but let's focus on the
cloud functions.  Within that
you can also get per function
logs.  So as you can see I have
a ton of a ton of a ton of
different functions running in
friendly picks.  Let's say I
only care about all of the
delete old post functions.  So
you can filter based on that and
see a list of every sirn gel one
of those that's happened.  You
can go back to the full one.
You can also see things
registered by errors or
warnings.  So filter based on
that and I think there is some
regular expression filtering as
well.  If you know what you are
looking for you can start typing
and say hey, let's see on
succeeded.
Succeed.  Let's try that.
Nothing found.  Darn.  Okay.
So logging, and then let's pop
over to error reporting.
So you can see friendly picks is
three throwing a couple of
errors in production.
Error permission
denied last occurred 20 hours
ago.  It will load and tell us
hey this part in your code you
can actually see a bunch of
other errors that have been
thrown.
Maybe we should go and fix that.
The other thing you can say hey,
maybe I actually don't care
about this.
We will mark it as resolved.  Go
back.
And it no longer shows up.  So
we filtered.  Maybe I actually
do care about the
resolved and I can see it there.
It is a nice way of managing the
kind of day-to-day operations of
your
application.  Okay.  Pop over to
the Stackdriver console.  And
you can see that same dashboard
that I showed you earlier.  We
have data stored and bandwidth.
We have a the number of database
requests and number of storage
requests.  I want to know when
are my functions executing and
what's happening to them.  So
I'm going to go and say add a
chart.
We will call this functions
executions.  Cloud functions.
And you can see that we have a
metric called executions.
That's a count of executions
broken down by status code, for
instance.  And you can actually
see the name of the function,
and the value in kind of number
of executions per second.  If I
wanted to I could also group by
say the function name.  And you
will get not only -- this is
kind of the aggregate sum of all
of the things that are happening
in my function.  But I could if
I wanted to.
Instead filter by give me
functions that are okay.  So
only give me the functions that
are succeeding or only give me
the functions that are failing.
And maybe here I also want to
group
by the function name.
And we will save that.  And it
will actually give me the
historical information as well.
So you can see this one
particular day May 7th a couple
of days ago we had a
huge spike and we were getting
two cleanup account requests
every second for this little
period of time.  And actually
you can see that, there is a
sliding line on the screen.
So you can actually time
correlate
across different things
.  You can also ind kind of zom
in and I want to look at this
particular time.  Between 2 p.m.
and 2:10 p.m.
we had a huge spike and that
corresponded to a bunch of
changes in
database and storage and
function.  You can see exactly
what's going on
across the different products.
Speaking of alerting we can hop
over.  We can look at, for
instance, the alerting policy on
that velocity alert.
You can see nothing interest can
has happened.  Maybe we want to
edit it.  We have say found out
that it doubling is not that
troubling.  Like that.  That
rhymed.
But let's edit that and say if
it goes
up by 500% we want to change
that.  We can save the condition
and save the policy and if
something changes, we will get
alerted about it.  I will try
one that I think is going to be
fun.
So it looks like we have just
about a gigabyte of data.
I'm going to set up a -- I'm
going to
change my storage over quota
threshold.  I will edit that and
I will actually
just say -- so it is currently
at 5 gigabytes.
I will set that to -- that's
still higher than what I have.
So we will drop that -- there we
go.  So we will drop it below
the threshold and we will save.
We will save that and I'll keep
going through the demo.
But at the end you can see I
have e-mail tabs over here.
I will see if it will send me an
e-mail to say that that thing
fired and I should go and deal
with it.
It may take awhile, we only kind
of check once a day what the
bucket size is.
But I can do things like
database requests or storage
requests or function executions
that are updated more frequently
or get alerted more frequently
there.  Okay.  So lastly we are
going to set up budget alerts.
So going back I want to say this
is a server that I am running
myself.  I am paying for this
with my personal credit card.
I want to know when I am
spending $50 a month.  I have
set up an alert that says notify
me when this project is over $50
a month and I can set up
percentage alerts as well.
When I am at $25, $45 and $100 a
month.  This is not going to
shut my server down.  Everything
is going to keep going.
So let's kind of of a two edged
sword.  If your website goes on
hacker news and get this huge
load spike you don't
want the "hug of death" where
everyone
goes on hacker news and your
sweb
website is returning 429 the or
402s for
quota exceeded website ir
errors.
If you want you can also
programmatically manage these.
If you you could hook up Pub/Sub
to a cloud function to go
anywhere you want.  So there are
a lot of really nice
integrations.
I will save this, I'll move it
back down to 10 and I will
actually see if I can quota
alert myself.  So I changed it.
I have already spent $18.  It
should probably send me an
e-mail oh, my God, Mike you are
blowing through all of your
money.  You should stop.  We
will actually pop over.  I have
filters.  So unfortunately it
doesn't look like
that's storage one fired but I
have kind of a bunch of
historical alerts from
Stackdriver.  Here is what they
look like.
You can say hey this is what it
started.  And here is the
project.  You can view it.  It
will pop you back over to the
Stackdriver console and then
once it is resolved, again you
get that nice resolution e-mail.
And I'll see if I got another
e-mail from the other billing
alert.  No, it doesn't look like
it.  But again here is a
previous one that I fired.  Sent
it hey, you have hit 100% of
your $50 a month budget.
Maybe you should go deal with
that.  Let's go back to the
slides.
So John started the presentation
by
talking about what Firebase
provides to make sure that your
organization can use it.  The
fine grained control that you
and
your team need so that, you
know, I'm not mucking around,
sending crazy push notifications
or screwing with data in the
database.
I'm only doing exactly what I in
my role need.
John also showed how you can
provide a great foundation for
compliance and legal
requirements through Firebase.
So your lawyers are going to be
happy with it.  And lastly we
just went through how Firebase
handles global scale and gives
you visibility in to everything
that's happening in your app
both from a production
standpoint as well as a
financial standpoint.
So yes, Firebase is ready for
work.  Thank you all very much
for coming.  John and I will be
over in the
Firebase Flutter and cloud sandz
sandbox after this talk.  We are
happy to talk to you about any
and all user needs.
Enjoy the last day of Google
I/O.
>> Thank you.
Grand ambassadors will assist
you to making room to the ex-sis
the.  Have you registered for
the next session in this room we
ask that you
please clear the room and return
via the registration line
outside.  Thank you.
>>.
>>
An accessible process for
inclusive design.
>>.
>>
Welcome.
Please fill in the seats near
the front of the room.  Thank
you.
>>.
>>
Welcome.  Thank you for joining.
Our session will begin soon
.
>>.
>>
Hi everybody.  Thanks for
coming.  We are really excited
to have you all here today.
My name Jen Devins.  I lead the
user experience team for Google
accessibility and with me I have
Andrea Wong, she is a researcher
on accessibility.
Catherine Idylle who is a
designer on accessibility and
Bethany Fong, who is
the lead designer on Google
material design.  We are happy
to have a great crowd that's
interested in inclusive design
and accessibility.
And we are looking forward to
sharing with you how you can
make your products more
inclusive.
But before we dive in and get in
to specifics we wanted to start
with some basics.  What is
accessibility and inclusive
design and why it is important.
As describe by the web
accessibility
initiative, accessibility
usability and inclusive design
are all very closely related.
Their goals approaches and
guidelines overlap
significantly.  And when we sit
down to design and
develop our apps, it is really
effective to address them
together.
Let's start with accessibility.
Accessibility focuses on
enabling
users with disabilities to
perceive
interact, understand, and
navigate tools and services and
products.  And that they can
contribute equally without
barriers.  Now some of the
guidelines we think
about with accessibility such as
clearer
color contrast, or clearer
concise writing are useful not
only to users
with disabilities but also those
that might be -- or that don't
have disabilities but might be
in different situations.
For example, we know that
alternative text can be useful
to users who are blind and can't
see the screen as it describes
the imaginary and visual icons.
Alternative text can also be
useful to users who might be out
in remote
locations with low bandwidth or
using old technology.
Another example it is clear that
providing enough time for users
to interact with and read
content on the screen is useful
for users who might have a motor
impairment or cognitive
impairment.
This extra time is also very
useful for users that might be
learning a new
language or have low literacy or
children learning to read or
people distracted.
And this is how accessibility is
a key component of inclusive
design.
And inclusive design is all
about
considering the wide range of
human abilities.
We think of age, gender,
ethnicity, and others.  And as
you can see accessibility
overlaps significantly with
these areas as well.
And that's why we feel like
accessibility is a really clear
starting point.
So at this point we could just
throw
up on the screen a checklist of
guidelines for you to follow to
ensure to make sure that your
product is accessible and that's
a great place to start, no doubt
about it.
However what we have seen is may
often
lead to a product that's
technically accessible but not
necessarily useable let alone a
great experience for all users.
And this is where usability
comes in to play.  Now how many
people by a quick show of hands
take time to reach out and get
feedback and input from users?
Quick show of hands.  It is an
important and really useful
thing to do, right?
Unfortunately, we know that a
lot of users with disabilities
are left out of this really key
critical point in the process.
If we are not out there talking
and
observing our users, we will
never understand what are their
true experiences.
What are their challenges
.  And most importantly what are
their insights that could
actually benefit everyone.  And
in the end you could be left
missing out on a large number of
potential users and also miss
out on
helping existing users who might
be in these limiting situations.
Okay.
So that's the basics.  We got
the stage set.
Now we want to walk you through
more of a case study to
demonstrate how to design and
develop with accessibility in
mind.  We are going to today we
are going to
use our fictional app called
Crane and we are going to use
this throughout the rest of the
talk to demonstrate specifics of
how
to make products more inclusive
as well
as material design system which
includes clear guidelines,
components and tooling.
Okay.  So to get this started we
are going to
break it down in to four primary
stages.
We have defining a product
vision,
design development and after
design.  Now this framework
probably seems familiar to you.
And that's on purpose.  We are
not here to introduce yet
another process for you to
follow.
Instead we she as a toolkit of
ideas and things that you can do
to enhance
your product to make it more
inclusive.
Because in the end inclusive
design is really just simply
good design.
Okay.
So now Andrea is going to walk
through
the first stage of defining the
product vision.
>> ANDREA WONG: Stage 1,
defining the production vision.
No matter what you are building,
understanding what problems or
solving for users is a key to
product success.  So who are
your users?  Most teams start
with the assumption
that all their users are fully
abled.  But that may not always
be the case.
So let's say you are building a
photos app and you think well,
why would
someone who was blind use my
photos app.  A person who is
blind may use your app because
they want to take photos and
then share them with friends and
families or post them on social
media just like everyone else.
Consider these three people on
the screen.
There is a man in a wheelchair
with
Lou Gerig's disease.  There a
boy with a broken arm and
there a woman holding a full bag
of groceries.  Let's have a pop
quiz.  Which of these three
people have limited mobility?
Raise your hand if you think it
is the
man in the wheelchair
.  Okay.  Hands down.  Raise
your hand if you think it is the
boy.  Thank you.  And lastly
raise your hand if you
think it is the woman
.  So if you raised your hands
all three
times you are correct.
All three of them have a
different relationship with
limited mobility whether it is
permanent like the man,
temporary like the boy.  Or
situational like the woman with
the groceries.  Yet they are all
experiencing the exact same need
right now.
It is a good reminder that for
every single one of us we will
have accessibility needs at some
point throughout our lifetime.
Disability is a much broader
term than we might think.  And
often when something doesn't
work well for a user with no
disabilities that pain point is
amplified for people with
disabilities.  And that's
actually good news for you.
Because it gives you much
clearer
signals of what you should be
focusing
on because when everything
doesn't -- when something
doesn't work for everyone it
clearly is something you should
be paying attention to.  And
that's in fact, what we found
with our studies at Google.  All
users have the same core needs
because they are all trying to
meet the same goal, whether it
is sending a
photograph, writing an e-mail,
buying crypto kitties whatever
it is.  You are probably asking
how do I do research with people
with disabilities?  The answer
is do what you usually do.
Are you let's say in the early
stage right now where you are
just chatting and sitting down
and talking to users?  If you
are, that's actually the easiest
and the best time to be
including users with
disabilities inies in to your
process.  You can get their
contexts and needs right from
the very start.  You can ask the
exact same questions as you
would to someone without
disabilities.
The only difference is you have
to ask
a few additional questions about
the assistive technologies that
they are using and their context
of use.
So, for example, you will be
asking say how do you use your
assistive
technologies when you are
navigating a mobile device.  How
does it impact your interactions
when you are planning travel or
maybe even which work arounds if
any, do you use to get to what
you need.
And always always follow up
after each question with why.
Tell me more.  To really dig in
there to give the context of
their needs.  The bonus here is
their answers may inspire new
ways of interactions that you
have never thought of before.
Or maybe you are passed that
stage already.  Right now you
are testing a low Fidelity like
paper prototype.  That's fine.
You can still test people with
disabilities.  Let's say you are
testing with a user
who is blind and uses a screen
reader which is an assistive
technology that reads out loud
the content on the screen.  So
you are doing that.  But you
don't have a screen reader
friendly prototype.  What you
can do here though is write a
script of what the screen reader
might verbalize and have someone
on your team act as a screen
reader.  And that person can
read each step outloud to the
user as they walk through
the user flow during the study
session.
By integrating people with
disabilities whenever you are
talking to people without
disabilities you are
automatically ensuring that
their viewpoints will be
included in part of the process
throughout the entire design
and development phases.
Along with understanding user
needs you
need to have a general
comprehension of assistive
technologies.  And the
difference tools that people
may use interact with your
product.  Trying the
technologies yourself is a great
place to start.
But the best way to learn is to
observe the real experts.  Those
are the people who use these
technologies day in and day out
and if you can't find someone to
observe in real life, that's
okay.
You can just go online and look
for any kind of video.  There
are countless great videos
online to explain the different
ways that people use different
technologies.  The goal here is
to understand what makes a good
versus a poor experience.  What
are the common pitfalls and the
standard expectations that
people have when using your site
or app.
Later using our fictional app
Crane we'll walk you through
designing a great keyboard
navigation model.
Starting with the keyboard
navigation model creates a very
good foundation for
you when building for other
assistive technologies which we
won't go in to here.  You may be
feeling a bit overwhelmed right
now in how to design to meet all
these needs.
But the great thing about design
inclusively is that people and
teams have been working for
years to understand what design
incloousively means.
Material design
sign components -- doing the
right thing
though isn't necessarily
mutually exclusive to good
business sense either.
You can even increase your
market share.  According to the
American institute of research
who came out with this report a
few months ago working age
people with disabilities in the
U.S.
alone have a discretionary
income of 21 billion dollars.
That's the third largest market
segment in the entire country.
Then if you think about their
families and friends, who may
also use your product to
interact with them, or, you
know, they may just simply
appreciate good design, and this
is not just the U.S. alone.
According to Gartner people with
disabilities and their friends
and
family worldwide have a
collective
disposable income of 8 trillion
dollars.
Think about that.  Okay.
That was a lot of information.
So let's go over the important
points to keep in mind.
One, talk to people with
disabilities to inform their
product vision.  Two, learn
assistive technologies from the
experts.  And three, build a
better experience
for all users and potentially
capture more market share.  Now
I'm going to hand it over to
Catherine who is going to go
over stage 2, design.  You are
right here.
>> CATHERINE IDYLLE: Thanks
Andrea.
(Applause.)
>> CATHERINE IDYLLE: Hi.
Now that you have defined your
product vision it is time to
design your app.  You will need
to think about
interaction design, visual
design, UX writing and motion
design but don't worry, we will
do design challenge
together using our fictional app
Crane to learn how to do this.
So Crane is a travel and
hospitality app that lets users
book flights and
accommodations on a computer or
phone.  In terms of interaction
design, you might be wondering
how do I even get started
designing accessible and useable
experience for everyone.  Well,
design as you normally do, have
your Wireframes and your
sketches and get started there.
This is a Wireframe of filter
options on mobile when you
search for a flight on Crane.
Here we can see that the check
boxes are aligned with the label
but they are pretty far apart.
When designing your layout
ensure that related content and
controls are grouped together.
This makes it easier to
understand and
also easier to reach for people
with motor disabilities.
Especially for people with ALS,
or a traveller on a bumpy train.
So we did here is that we placed
a check boxes right next to the
labels.  It is a better
experience for everyone.
In terms of interaction design,
you
can also have a huge impact on
all users by thinking about the
tab interaction model.  Meaning
a great keyboard experience.
Here we have a Wireframe on web
of the flight search results.
Tabbing on the keyboard allows
you to jump from one interactive
element on the
screen as we can see right here.
This will be the default tab
experience if we didn't design
it at all.
It would take 94 tabs stops to
go from point A the back button
to point B the filter options.
This is a slow experience.
So what we can do is actually
group
major elements together, like
this list of individual flights.
Now at it only takes 7 tap stops
to reach point B.  And once you
have grouped your big tab stops
together don't forget how to
quickly navigate to the smaller
elements
such as the individual flights
and this big list of flights.
Here we will go with an upand
down arrow option to navigate
between them.
Overall this is a much better
and
productive experience for power
users
much like yourselves right here,
and assistive tech users alike.
Here is some things that we can
do to make your app more
accessible in terms of
interaction design.  Group your
content, and your controls
together.  Design your tab
interaction model.  And don't
forget the error navigation as
well.
Now on to Bethany to talk about
visual design.
(Applause.
)
>> BETHANY FONG: Thanks,
Catherine.  So now that we have
laid a good foundation in terms
of interaction
design, let's refine our
visuals.  To start with the very
basics.
I am sure you have felt the pain
of
light gray text on light gray
background.  So the No.
1 way that you can be a hero for
these users is ensuring that
color contrast is between your
foreground and background colors
is going to be high enough and
you can use our material color
tool pictured here to check the
ledgibility of your choices and
check them against different
background colors.
Like the three shades of purple
here.  So let's apply this.
Going whack back it our app,
these
faded colors that you see are
trendy but the contrast is so
low that it is hard for even
most sighted users to have a
legible experience here.  And
remember this is going to be
better not just for users with
low
vision, but someone with dilated
eyes after a doctor's
appointment or people like
yourselves out in the sun all
day with glare on your screen.
So let's add more color
contrast.
First we are going to zoom in on
how we can add contrast in to
the text field component.  We
increase the font weight and
color darkness in the text
fields which makes
it easier to scan and ensures a
better visual hierarchy.  And we
also increase the background
color darkness on the button at
the bottom.  Making the text
more legible and making the call
to action much easier to spot
which is really important
because you are trying to get
your users to purchase something
here.  And already with the
before and after you can see
that this is a much better
design.
Other than just looking more
aestheticically pleasing the
text is more legible and the
call to action are a lot easier
to spot.
So now your user is filling in
their information in toe these
much better text fields and
getting closer to booking that
flight but it looks like
they made an error.  However
some users will color blindness
might miss this important piece
of information.  And this can be
fixed by supplementing any
information that's coded in
color
through other means like icons
or shapes.  So we are going to
check out the material icon site
and search for error icons.  It
is good to use essential
resource
like this because thee are
common visual metaphors that ma
may be recognizable to a wide
variety of users.  It looks like
we can go ahead and use this
one.  We are going to download
and now there are two ways to
understand that this is
an error state and this makes it
clearer for everyone, not just
users who are color blind.  And
for our last visual design
example let's look at focus
state and element size on
screen.  So when users choose a
seat in this travel app, it is
important that they can select
the seat that they want and that
they know their selection was
success ful.
This means having a touch target
size about 7 millimeters wide
which is calibrated against a
size of adult fingertip.  And on
web try to ensure that your
focus is highly visible.  You
can see it as the bold purple
joult line around seat 8A.
So when you are doing your
visual design when keeping it
accessible make sure you have
high color contrast and you have
multiple visible indicators for
any important component states
and lastly make sure that your
touch target sizes are going to
be large enough for people to
reach.  Back over to Catherine.
(Applause.)
>> CATHERINE IDYLLE: Thanks,
Bethany.  I'm back.  With
writing you have the power to
guide all users with accessible
onscreen text as well as
meaningful offscreen text that
will be verbalized by the screen
reader.
A screen reader is software that
sits between you and the
application and it works in
tandem with the chi board.  The
keyboard moves the focus and the
screen reader will verbalize
whatever has come in to focus.
We have these example from
Google.com if you heard of it
and it will read
this button as Google search
button because the screen reader
automatically reads out loud the
label Google search and the
control type button.
So back to our Crane app.  We
have a checkout screen.  Let's
just focus on these four
buttons.  And remember the
screen reader automatically
reads out loud the control type.
So it will verbalize these
buttons as
button button button button.
That's problematic.
We don't know what the buttons
will do and the cancel order and
complete order actions are right
next to each other which could
lead to major user error.
Instead what we can do is add
meaningful, and concise
accessible labels in addition to
the default button
verbalization.
So here we have added previous
step, checkout progress, cancel
order, and checkout order.
Now we know what each button
will do
and they won't be a major gaff
of canceling an order rather
than
completing one and vice versa.
You can be a champion for screen
reader
users by writing access to your
labels in addition to the
default verbalization
provided by screen readers.
In terms of motion design, have
your had something important
flash before your eyes?  Blink
and then be gone?  This just
happened to you.
It is a major pain point for
users of low vision or someone
who wasn't paying attention.
Try to ensure that alerts like
snack bars are presented on the
screen long enough so that
everyone can see them, like
right now.  And have an option
to easily dismiss them, like a
dismiss button or tapping out
function.
Likewise consider supporting
screen magnification users.
Here on web when a user hovers
over a seat they get additional
information about that seat in a
hover card.  But it covers the
rest of the screen when
magnified.  To help our users
get back to whatever
they are doing, consider an easy
escape patch.
Such as escape key shortcut or a
close button.
To ensure that your motion
design accessible present an
alerts for long enough and have
an option to easily dismiss
them.
Likewise, easily escape hover
information during screen
magnification
.  At this stage we have
designed the
interactive visual, writing, and
motion aspects of our product.
Now it is time to talk to users.
Get some feedback and check if
you are on the right track.
Also see if you ran in to any
major
blockers that you didn't
consider.
It consists of having a small
set of examiners evaluate your
app.  Otherwise called
heuristics.  So right here we
have three heuristics from the
material design accessible
guidelines and they are clear,
they are robust and specific.
So let's check.
Is your app clear, meaning are
its
layout noncrowded and calls to
action visually distinct?  Is
your app robust?  Does it
support a variety of user
capabilities.  Finally is your
app specific?  Does it
specifically support a variety
of user technologies in the ways
that the user expects?
Let's try this out with Crane.
We have two button variations
and we
want to see if it is clear
enough for low vision users.
Well, we may find that these two
buttons have the same color
contrast but may also find that
people prefer the one on the
right because the shopping cart
icon makes the purpose of the
button
more obvious.  After completing
your product conduct your
heuristic evaluation and feel
free to use the accessibility
guidelines provided by material
design.  Is your app clear?
Robust?  And specific?
Now back to Bethany on how to
develop your app.
>> BETHANY FONG: Thanks
Catherine.
(Applause.
)
>> BETHANY FONG: So you have
moved on to the development
stage.  And you want to make
sure that all of those decisions
you just made in the design
stage hold through to the final
product.
So the first thing you can do is
use
stand dard components when
designing.  If you use material
components they
will be pre vetted and they will
be useable and recognizable to
your users.
If you use something nonstandard
note that you will props have to
design the full component
yourself as well as marking it
out with the appropriaty
metadata.  You will need to
provide labels, struck is it
your and paths.  And designers
one tool that you can use is
gallery.  Created by Google to
help you manage design
iterations and get quick design
feedback.  If you use our
material theme editor with
sketch which is a popular design
tool and upload your mocks to
gallery you will see all
measurements or red
lines as designers call them.
You can see here how large this
price text is and make sure that
the touch target size is going
to be large enough to be tapible
for people with hand tremor.
You can also use it to
communicate back and forth with
your team about
accessibility markup and any
verbalizations.
Don't forget to use scaleable
text.  This allows for a piece
of text to scale up or down
according to the user's
individual seat settings.  But
urnl the rest of the UI remains
the same size.  So follow this
specific platform standards for
how scaleable text should be
implemented.
And here is the same screen with
the large text.  You can
actually read it which is great.
Engineers you can keep users
with various impairments in mind
as a designer would consider a
user with low vision, no vision
or some mobility challenges.
One way of focusing this work is
to schedule periodic bug patches
and fix lets from accessibility
point of view and a number of
tools that you can use during
development to check your
accessibility on web and on
Android.
These include accessibility
scanner on Android because it
checks your app
screen by screen for any
accessibility
errors and come by the
accessibility sandbox to learn
about other dev tools that you
can use during your process.  As
you are developing don't forget
to
use common compon nents when you
can.  Use scaleable text and use
accessibility development tools
throughout your process to check
yourself as you go.  All right.
>> JEN DEVINS: Thanks.
So now
Dev.
>> ANDREA WONG: Now I'm going
to talk about the last stage,
stage 4 after development.  The
bulk of development work is
complete and you are about to
launch.
This -- at this time we
recommend using a tool like
prelaunch report from the Google
Play store.  Some of you may
already be using
prelaunch report but the good
news is it now includes
accessibility.
So upload your app to Alpha beta
channel and it will crawl
through your app to identify a
number of ways to improve it.
Like crashes, latency issues,
and, of course, accessibility.
And you won't need to instrument
your app ahead of time.
For the web, we recommend
automated accessibility tools
that's built right in to our
Chrome dev tools.
So inside the audit's pan nel
you will see a tool called light
house.
Light house will run about 40
automated tests against your
site to check for common
accessibility issues.
When it is finished, it will
give you a score.  It will point
out the failing elements
and the best part is will link
you to documentation with
instructions on how to fix those
failing elements.  And if you
have done everything right up to
this point, you have listened to
all of us, then everything here
should be a breeze.
One more thing, no great
onboarding experience is
complete without good help
content.
And help content is a resource
that people with disabilities
often utilize.
So make sure you include in help
content on accessibility and
make sure
that content is actual tli
accessible.  This is a great
opportunity to help all users
get off to a great start with
your app or your product.  And
recover quickly when they get
stuck.
Yay!  You have launched.  Now
that we are here you are
probably going through your
metrics and Analytics and
checking the effectiveness of
your
launch and user engagement and
so forth.
You are hopefully also doing
user
studies and measuring
satisfaction to see how well
your app has been received by
everyone.  At this point include
respondents with accessibility
needs so that you are hearing
all the feedback.
This is also the perfect time to
stop and understand what
benefits your team
has reaped from design
inclusively from the very
beginning.
Decide what to cut and what to
keep and what to change and
apply to the next cycle.  Over
time design inclusively will
become second nature to you.
Let's go over the main points.
One, check the common
accessibility
issues with prelaunch report and
higt light house.  Make sure you
have accessibility help
content that's access accessible
and get feedback from users
with with disabilities.
>> JEN DEVINS: All right.
So there you have it our toolkit
of ideas that hopefully you can
apply to your process.
We know it is a lot of
information.  There a lot of
great resources out there that
you can rely on.
We wanted to leave you with one
thing you can do during each
stage of the
process starting today.
So if you are starting out and
you are defining your product
vision can't stress it enough,
get out there and talk to users.
If you are curious of where
should I find users with
disabilities, I don't know
anyone, there is lots of
organizations nationally and
internationally that you can
reach out to and they will often
put you in contact with their
members.  And in fact, today in
the design and accessibility
sandbox across the way there are
members from the National
Federation of the Blind that are
willing and wanting to give you
feedback or just answer your
questions.
If you are in the design stage,
you probably started working on
your
interaction workflow model and
you are thinking about it, have
it drafted, before you get too
far take a step back
and think how would a user that
is using a keyboard go through
this interaction model.  This is
a great place to start and you
will be very happy you did this
earlier than later.
If you are in a development
stage, use standard components.
They have been stress tested and
they are familiar to users which
is great.  You don't want users
to have to
relearn their app or -- for each
screen.  And finally if you are
nearing that
finish line, and it is after
velt after development just as
Andrea mentioned we recommend
that ensure you have accessible
onboarding and help
content and if it makes sense
for your
app to have act accessibility
onboarding materials.
We all have the power and
responsibility to remove
barriers, and
empower all users to be
productive and connected.
Thank you so much for your time.
(Applause.
)
>> JEN DEVINS: If you are
interested in learning nor r
more you can attend the
accessibility and design sandbox
right next door.  Thank you.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  Grand ambassador will
assist with
directing you through the
designated exits.  If you are
registered for the next session
in this room, we ask that you
please clear the room and return
via the registration line
outside.
Thank you
. T.
>>.
>>
Integrate your smart home device
with
the Google assist tnt
ant
Smart Home device with the
Google Assistant.
Gast
oogle Assistant.
>>.
>>
.
Welcome.  Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
>>.
>>
Welcome.  Thank you for joining.
Our session will begin soon.
>>.
>>
.
>> Hello and good morning.
Thank you for joining our
session.  I'm.
>> MARK SPATES: Mark Spates and
I brought a few of my colleagues
with me.
>> I'm Michele Turner.
>> I'm David Schairer.
>>.
>> MARK SPATES: When whe
started this project a couple of
years ago we
had a vision and our vision was
to have
the Google Assistant to be the
center of interaction.
We selected the word intelligent
for a very specific reason.  We
believed that users would demand
that air assistant in their home
understand the environmental
context as well as the device
capabilities when
they start to control these
devices.
To achieve this goal last year
we launched the ability to
integrate Smart
Home devices using the actions
on Google platform.  Actions on
Google is our platform for
developers to create experiences
around
education, games and many others
through the Google Assistant.
When it came the Smart Home one
thing
that we focused on was having a
seamless easy experience for
developers to connect these
devices to the assistant.
We also understood that we had
to allow this contextual
understanding that we were
beaning from the home and
devices also to be actcessible
to our
developers and we created the
home graph.  This is a very
simple visual representation of
the home graph.
The home graph is the key to
these intelligence interactions
that we have with users.  I will
just walk through it quickly.
If you look at it it is broken
down in to three main parts.
The first part is the structure.
Understanding the structure and
the
name of the structure address 9
of the
structure a, what devices in the
structure.  What's the presence
of this structure.
Then the next thing that we look
at are rooms.
Rooms are extremely important
signals when you think about
interacting with an assistant.
Command in the living room
versus the kitchen can mean very
different things.  So when you
look at the room level we are
saying what is the name of this
room and what devices are in
this room.  The third and
probably one of the most
important components are
devices.  When we look at the
metadata we want to get from
devices it things like
names, types, trait, attributes
and state.  If you combine these
three elements
you start to see how we are
building our understanding and
contextual relevance to help
users get to the exact control
that they want.
>> DAVID SCHAIRER: So we
launched this last year.  We
have over 400 partners who have
used Smart Home API on access on
Google.  We hope that never goes
up and some of you guys leave to
start to create some of these
integrations for us.
The other cool part is we
control over 5,000 Smart Home
products on the market today.
So if you walk in to my of your
favorite electronic stores or
sites and look at these Smart
Home devices there is a good
chance that the Google
Assistant can actually control
it.  But we are seeing an
evolution.  When we first
started this I remember talking
to David and we are all excited
that we can *** say turn the
light on, turn the light off.
We are like oh, man we did it.
We just changed the world.  It
is our Edison moment.
That off and on was not enough.
We wanted to be able to have the
user speak to the assistant in
the way that
they speak to their partner or
spouse or children or family.
Than
And this evolution a very simple
thing.
Make it cooler, make it warmer.
The first step this we took we
decided
to make sure that every single
device
that we support it directly so
we had a deep understanding of
how the device works and what
are the traits that we need to
create so we can match them to
the grammar that the user will
want.  2016 we had a very small
start.  We had four devices but
you can see in 2017 we brought
so many devices to the market
that we support directly and we
understand with deep knowledge
from
cameras, doorbells, washers and
dryers,
sensors, air purifiers.  There
are tons.  All the way to tubs
and toilets.  There will be a
day where you talk to your tub
and there is a trait about it.
And David will tell you about
it.
But let me just walk you through
quickly, who we using machine
learning to create a better user
experience.  This is a very
simple graph but if you
think about this light to the
user to a five-year-old they
have point at it and say mommy
daddy that's a light.  What we
want to understand about that
light is a little bit different.
We want to know what's the name
of that light.
What traits does it have.
Does it support color,
brightness and state.
Because that allows us to take
the right action to make the
lights in -- dim the lights in
the living room on make the
lights in the living room
brighter.
We are going back to that home
graph and say what's the name of
that light and where is it
located and what's the current
state and current brightness.
It is X.  We will raise it by Y.
This is how we are starting to
take this data that we are
having about the home and
devices and make it a better
user experience.  But it just
doesn't stop with lights.
Lights is easy.  Think about all
the other devices in your home.
So you will be able to say hey
Google
raise the tomorrow temperature a
little bit.
Hey Google dry my clothes or
start vacuuming.  It is like hey
clean the house.  But these are
the type of things that we
believe you will start to see
from
the Google Assistant because we
built
this cool Backend with
contextual understanding and
deep understanding of devices.
So give you more about how as a
developer you can take advantage
of this David will walk you
through actions on Google.
>> DAVID SCHAIRER: Thanks.
We spent the last year E panning
this
platform and we launched it a
year ago on I/O.
We had maybe a dozen, 20
partners and
now we are 400 partners, 5,000
devices device products.
We have also got tens of
thousands of developers playing
with this.  And later we are
going to talk about how we do
that.  I was going to walk
through a little bit about how
this works.  We do have a cloud
to cloud integration.
For most of our partners in the
ooit IoT space.
It is very easy to take that
cloud integration and plug it in
to our lightweight API.
Most of our partners no greater
than
six weeks that's end to end of
start of project.  We need to do
to make sure that everything is
good to go.
We have partners that do the
work in under a day because it
is just that easy.
And as Mark said I will go in to
a
little more detail we use these
concepts called types and
traits.
This is the pla tonic washing
machine.  There is a type of
device called washing machine.
It is a type that tells us a
little
about it and that lets us learn
that we can call it a washing
machine and let it look like a
washing machine.  It is like a
duck in that regard.  But it
doesn't tell us what that
washing machine does.  It has
its own state, own settings,
one of them has a, you know,
permanent and press mode.
All of that is where we go to
traits
and we use traits at building
blocks of
this Smart Home and this lets
partners
innovate in their own way in new
-- in new ways which is what we
did ot our demo if you go to our
sandbox.
We have somewhat demo mailbox
here on stage and show you who
you we built this later but this
mailbox and the sandbox
no one of our partners has built
a smart
mailbox before but we did this
for the demo because all the
traits were there.  Camera,
light.  On off for the light and
toggle for
the flag and object detection
for mail
based on the ex-sigsisting
functionality we have.
Understands state, understands
change
and as you can well imagine a
lot of the Google sequence sauce
and machine learning and
intelligence starts to operate
on the things we learned from
the home graph we start to be
able to take all of these
devices and actually truly make
the Smart Home smart.
All of this today you can int
great with one API.  It is very
simple.  You let us query
devices and execute devices and
tell us the devices are there.
You can call us back at any
time.  They will push state
changes.  Change of device is so
-- that's all you do.
One little rest full E API.  We
have a reference and limitations
we will show you and lots of
documentation.
A full team of developer
relations and support engineers
to help you.  You don't need to
do internationalization.  You
don't need to do UI.  Everything
like ha is provided for you.
And as can imagine with all of
the
other devices we are going to be
rolling it out.
So this sort of the status quo
we are in today.  I am going to
turn it back to Michele to talk
about the fun stuff coming next.
>> MICHELE TURNER: Thanks.
So as Mark mentioned and David
mentioned we have spent the last
couple of years building this
platform out.  And now we are in
a state where we are able to add
a lot of new features to really
build on the intelligence and
help you guys create better and
more integrated and interactive
experiences.  At the end of the
day what we all want
to do is create solutions or to
problems that people have in
their homes.  Things that they
are going to use every day.  And
so the fundamental features that
we are adding over the course of
this
year are going to help you do
that.  There are four main
features that we are adding for
the rest of this year.
Something called request sync,
report state, new object
detection trait, David is going
to show you and some new things
for entertainment devices.  So
let's start with request sync.
Request sync is really very
simple.
Right now if I go to the store
and I
go buy another half dozen smart
lights
to go put in my home I have to
add those devices and they don't
necessarily -- the fact that I
have added those devices don't
get synced up on to the partner
app very quickly.
And so what we are doing with
request
sync is you push the state to
the Google Cloud to let us know.
It goes in to home graph.  So I
go out to the store, I get my
new devices and I screw them in.
We bring them -- I pair them up.
Get them going and they
automatically just work.
Today if I did that, I would
have to unlink and relink and
that's a real hassle for most
users.  We have taken that
uncomfortable step out for users
and made it easier for you and
made it a lot easier for
customers.
One of the painful points is
just getting started even with
things like lights.  So making
that onboarding process simpler
and easier is really important
and that's part of what request
sync does.
We have also added a new API for
report state.  Report state is
really important.  And it is --
I will tell you why it is even
more important than ever.  I
spent a lot of time talking to a
number of you in the sandbox the
last couple of days about why we
need report state.
So imagine a situation where you
go up and you change your therm
stat on the wall.  I shift it
from 65 to 72.  What we normally
do on the Backend we poll you to
figure out when it this device
has been updated.
But you all saw the new displays
and the new user interfaces for
the phone in the keynote.  Well,
now we have new user interfaces
on these smart displays and on
phones that will show the
devices.
And with report state when you
push
report state to us and in to the
home graph we can get that state
information instantly.  So there
is no cognitive dissidence
between I just went over and
changed my
thermostat and my smart display
is still holding an old state of
temperature information.  It is
one of the things that we are
starting to require our
developers to give us so we make
sure that user experience for
our consumers is spot on.
The other reason you want to urs
report state is so that we are
not polling you all the time.
Which can get annoying and puts
a lot of load on your server
especially if you have very
active devices.
In the future report state is
going to
allow us to unlock a lot of I
will intelligence.  We can work
with you tougt to create more
Intel jenlt experiences.
Understanding in the kids room
the
light is turned out every night
at 7:30.
It is really important now and
it is going to be really
important in the future as we
start building more and
more intelligence.  So the next
feature I want to talk to
you about is object detection.
This is a trait.  We built in
trait a few months ago.
If you are familiar with the
doorbell
you may know this feature.  It
will actually let you know that
someone is at the door.  And we
did that integration using the
new object detection trait.
Let's take a look.
So if we
See if we can --
>> Someone's at the front
door.
>> MICHELE TURNER: If you
haven't seen that before, simple
push of the
button and it notifies on the
Google home mini through the
assistant.  What's really cool
about this trait is that it
actually changes the model and
this is one of the things I
really want to stress with you
we are trying to do at Google is
give you guys the ability to
create more interesting
integrations.
So with the object detection
trait normally the assistant
controls the device.  You say
okay, Google, turn on the
lights, right?
With this we take action on a
device, and it tells the
assistant to give a
notification.  Oops.  I just
fired the assistant.  So David
is going to come up right now
and show you a little bit more
of what
you can do with object
detection.
>> DAVID SCHAIRER: Cool.
Thanks.
So I'm going to do a demo here
of how notifications work.
Object detection is a specific
case of a general facility we
are adding to the
Smart Home where partners can
send notifications on objects.
And notifications become another
aspect of objects and devices
that you push in to the home
graph just like traits and
attributes and states and
commands and so forth other
aspects of devices.  And this
case notifications attach to
traits.
So just like in Java where you
have an object and the object
might see messages but might
declare, we declare a trait
you can -- you also are saying
hey this, for example, this
washing machine supports run
cycle.
Therefore it can now
send/receive depending on your
perspective notifications of
cycle errors.
The other washing machine failed
during the rinse cycle.  We
built this object detection as
the first case of this.
And like the video showed we
built it first use cases
doorbells but we build these
things as general cases, the
example in the lab in the
sandbox is for
mail detection and here we are
going to build something a
little more interesting.
But we are going to show you how
-- go back.  Register Smart Home
project and show
how linking works and show how
you can deploy your cloud
service and how notifications
are sent through in case no Jes
in Firebase from the device
itself and finally show you some
code and debugging tools.  This
is basically the flow of this
demo.
So this is a smart mailbox.
But it has very smart raspberry
pie down there.
And again not a shift in product
but easy demo that you can build
something like.
This the mailbox has a cloud
service that we have on
Firebase.
It sends a notification.
In this case it is a get request
with payload.  This sends to our
cloud service and cloud service
is where the smarts are.
Cloud service is also part of
our API it.  It sends
notification and notification
then goes in to the home -- goes
directly to the Google home I
have up here and you will see
that demo.  And all of this is
driven by the fact
that initially, initially the
mailbox
and other devices were synced
from the
partner service to the assistant
for my demo user and therefore
in the home
graph we know that this device
supports actually technically it
supports everything that the one
in the sandbox does that the
flag the lights, the
camera and so forth there is no
camera
in here but all the traits are
here.
I am going to hop on over to the
-- to
the laptop screen here.  Which,
of course, locked on me.  And
great.
So some of you saw this last
year.
We have re built this quite a
bit.  You need no command line
functionality for this now.
Those of us like me that missed
the command line are a little
sad.
But for the vast majority of
people -- no G actions.  This is
much more anyway native for us.
I am going to walk through a
very simple example and I am
short on time.
Of how you build a Smart Home
project today.  So I'm going to
add a project.  Now if you are
doing this, you pick a project
name.  Recommendation protip
from what we have dealt with
partners, pick a name that makes
sense.  No longer auto picking
names for you.  So you don't get
something like purple chaos
giraffes.  Pick a name.
So that said let's call this
purple chaos giraffe.  And that
creates spin spin spin.  Very
slow.  Because I am on stage and
it knows I am on stage.
This is creating a project in
the Google console with my
Google account up here.
And -- now I have all these
things.  This is the full
actions on Google.
So I can build a shopper app or
I
could build quote of the day
app.  All of those are using
conversational
actions but for Smart Home we
are really recommending and very
strongly recommending that you
are using these APIs.  Because
this is what give us home graph
and notifications and full
understanding the setup is in
fact, very quick.  So get up and
running this is going to take
only a couple of minutes.
I am going to name this
something random.
And I will then
-- and forgive me network is
especially slow today.  Account
linking.
Many of you have done this
already.
Mechanism for account linking.
This is pretty standard OLF.
Nothing out of the ordinary
here.  I'm going to make some
keyboard mash keys.
Do not use these keys at home
.  And, of course -- that is
protected by RFC.  Did you know
there is an actual RFC projected
example.com.
It is real
.  Testing is awesome
.  At this point we are pretty
much set up.  We are going to
create an action.
I need one thing.  I need the
end point for an action.
I am not going to set this one
up.
At this point I have now
deployed this and this will show
up on my phone.  I'm -- I have
now deployed this and it
will show up on my phone.  And
it will complain because I I
don't have that URL set up.  But
this is now set up on my phone
and it will be available in a
second to show that.  But
instead I'm going to switch back
over here to my stage demo fro
project.  This is the one that
we are actually using and here I
have got the actions set up.
It is pointed at a Firebase app.
And the Firebase app here is --
I'm
going to show you the Firebase
app.
You can debloi -- we get asked
this question a lot do I need
use Google Cloud, do I need to
use thread.
Google has -- as Google always
does a
number of technologies that you
can use to be a completely full
stack Google developer and if
you want to do that that's
awesome.
Tu a completely and totally not
required.  If you have an
existing cloud you can keep it.
You can greant this with any
infrastructure that you want.
You just need Internet decent
security
and int great lightweight API.
You can see to actually do all
the triggering and you can see
our trigger
types
here so on and so forth.  The
actual representation of the
commands that we run this thug.
through.  I am going to show you
a little code.
We have this implemented as a no
JS application.
This application is a slight
variant.  One that's in the
Codelab.  If you go over to the
Codelabs there is a Smart Home
Codelab that's building a
washing machine.  It is very
much this code.  There is --
this is also on github.  So you
can play with this yourself and
use this if you want as a
reference to limitation.
This is not a full -- you would
want
want to use this it is for IoT
product in market.  It doesn't
have a lot of the user
(inaudible) that you will want
for obviously one product.  But
it does a full reference and
limitation including a lot of
traits here.  And so just to
show you a little bit
what we are going to demo here
is primarily object detection
like Michele said but instead of
doing mail because
these things are extensible I am
going to show you how you might
build a product that deteks.  We
have some other needs for this
sort of thing.
But first let me show you how
you declare this.
So we have a sync handler:  It
is
basically just -- this is no JS.
Building the payload and that's
uninteresting.  The device list
here and the reference is
building devices.  So this is a
fixed list.  Your run this and
because there is no database it
defines a number of objects for
you.  You can use for tests.  So
here is, for example, a washing
machine as I was saying.
This washing machine implements
on off
and start stop and going to have
modes
for permanent press and hot,
cold, and
toggles for quiet mode and
bleach mode and it has a sensor
built in and then we
built down here somewhere a
mailbox
.  Hmmm.  A mailbox.  Of course,
it is the next one.  Here you
can see, these are all the
traits that we have used
including outgoing mail toggle
here is a little -- is this a
toggle.  We have a special code
for.
Because you have to do atributs
for toggle.
This is the things sensor and
flag and detection and see all
of these in action
go to the sandbox where the
camera is working and the flag
is working and with
that
let me show you the
notification.
Notification in this case again
no JS very simple.
It is taking a pass from the
payload,
from an HTPN point and box calls
our
implementation in Firebase and
it simply
then has hack line it simply
sends this
notification back through --
where is it?  The report state.
Report state and notifications
use the same call.
This uses a Java web token to
call us at any time.  It is how
you do sync and state
reporting and how you do
noteifications.  This is
running.
It is running in Firebase.
If you can switch to my phone
for a second I am going -- I
have already set this up.  I
have already connected to this
agent.  I have all the virtual
devices which of the devices in
the sandbox but I have got the
mailbox here.  Action no
commands on the mailbox but
I want to show you object
detection.
Object detection in this case,
implemented instead of doing
mail we implemented animal
detection because object
detection can detect anything.
This was supposed to be
originally a live demo.  Live
animal demo but our lawyers said
no, that was a liability and I
was being
grossly irresponsible.  So this
is no longer a live animal demo
but could I get the mic turned
on the Google home.  Thanks.  So
not a live animal demo.
But if all works well
(Laughter)
.
>> DAVID SCHAIRER:
>> There a raccoon in the
mailbox
(Laughter).
>> DAVID SCHAIRER: Kind of a
lame --
(Applause.
)
>> DAVID SCHAIRER: Kind of a
lame demo.
We are reusing the detection
logic for
mail and it is a little harder
on buzzy animals.
So it is a little tricky there.
You can see with the nest facial
which
to be fair is many, many more
thousands of engineering hours
of time but you can see you as
an IoT partner can do what you
do best.  You build a cool
device and we will handle all
the grammar and understanding,
notifications which go to now
you have access to the ecosystem
in the house.
You don't have to send messages
to
phones and we will see over the
coming
weeks and months we will be
adding notifications of a lot of
different types for security
events safety events
other notification.  You can
imagine when the oven timer is
going off and you want to know
that the roast is done.
You can now be two way in to the
smarter ecosystem.  And those
are things that will be rolling
out over the next coming months.
Minus the raccoon is in get --
in the sandbox.
You can do this with all off
your ecosystems.  This is on
Firebase.  Run on your own
cloud.  I know some other
companies out there ha have
clouds but you can run it
whoever you like on your
existing infrastructure.  You
can run anything you want in
your client.  We do have Android
things that you
should in this go and see the
Android things.
Sandbox very cool stuff.  We
have some cool projects that you
can integrate Android things.
We will be doing a lot more of
that.  Someone just showed me
this walk through, this is
actually last year.
But this walk through you can
find by
searching home automation and
Android things someone did an
easy walk through of Android
things running with the API and
you can do that walk through.
We also have -- we also have
several open source projects
natively integrated today.
So over here we have home
assistant somewhere.  Home
assistant right there in the
middle and we have open hab
which are both right there in
the middle which are open source
platforms that are already
integrated.
If you want to play with Smart
Home devices and don't want to
implement these home APIs. Th
last thing I wanted to show is
is a
developer tool, extensively in
the the last six months is we
are done a lot
more work to int great developer
tools in to the Google ecosystem
for Smart Home.
Switch back to the laptop.
Thank you.  So this here is hard
to read.
I apologize is the Stackdriver
for this account.  So here is
the I/O stage.  I have logged in
and all the errors
that we see on our side and I
had to generate some yesterday
to get this.
But last week all of these
errors are things that you would
not see because
they are outside of you
ecosystem.  We make a call to
the mailbox and the
mailbox fails but if Open Office
failing if sync data is wrong,
if the notification that you
send can't be
delivered after you have given
it to us.  So they are now going
in to stack driver and integrate
this with service and you can
Pub/Sub from Stackdriver.  If
you have another logging service
you can subscribe to your stack
level alerts and all of that is
now available and highly
recommended and makes the
development process much easier.
Please visit our -- visit the
Android
-- the Smart Home sand box.
We have lots of more demos like
this there.  Talk to us.
We have our development team
ready to support developers.  We
have folks answer questions
online.  We have other events
like this.
And throw us your questions of
we have a dedicated team of
folks just building new traits.
New device support every day.
We have a lot of stuff that is
available but not yet on the
public website.  If you see
something that you want, it is
not there.  Talk to us.  It is
probably something that we
already built.  So talk to us.
And with that I will turn it
back to Michele for one more
time.
>> MICHELE TURNER: Thanks.
That was awesome.  Does the
raccoon have a name?
>> DAVID SCHAIRER: His name
is Craig.
>> MICHELE TURNER: Craig?
>> DAVID SCHAIRER: We spent
significant time on this
yesterday.
>> MICHELE TURNER:
Excellent.  I will get the back
story later.  We do have one
more thing.  So we are
announcing here that we are
also opening up new APIs for
control of entertainment
devices.  And if you have been
to the sandz box you probably
seen the demo that we have
in the booth of the hopper box
that's currently working in
there.  That's our first
implementation and
will be launching in a few
weeks.  We will take a quick
look.
>> Switch to HGTV on the hopper
.
>> MICHELE TURNER: So there
we go.
It is switched to HGTV.
>> Switch to ESPN on the hopper
.
>> MICHELE TURNER: By the
way that's
Mark's and my cool little setup
in the office of the mini Smart
Home.
So these
media or entertainment devices,
like the one in my living room
that's a smart TV that has no
Voice interface or no mic, no
speaker, what we want to be able
to do is light up the assistant
to make home control easier for
those types of devices.  So what
we have done is we have
announced a set of traits and
this is a list of traits we
have.  Specific to entertainment
devices.  We have transport
control.  Gives you the ability
to move the media, rewind.  Fast
forward, et cetera.
Change the volume up and down
and get the state of the media
and do recording, understand
what channel you are on.  Mark
switching to the channels of we
played a lot of ESPN yesterday
and in
some cases we are also doing
media
initiation and this is by early
access partner only.  If you
happen to be at a company that's
doing entertainment devices
please come talk to us.  We will
be in the sandbox and happy to
talk to you more about this.
One other thing that I wanted
that I
mention
ed to mention, we have number of
surfaces in which your smart
devices will be shown.  Not only
through Voice control on a
variety of speakers but now on
the phone you will have the
newest assistant app that will
show the status of your smart
device on the phone and also on
all of the new intelligent
displays.  So multiple surfaces
for your smart
device to be displayed on and
interacted with.  So Mark
mentioned this earlier, that
we are up to 400 partners and
over 5,000 devices of these are
just some of the
partners that we have launched
since CES which was in January.
So we are growing very fast.
We have added new partners like
LG,
dish, Hisense, Panasonic,
Xiaomi.  If you are thinking
about getting started in Smart
Home come talk to us.
As David mention ed we in the
Google
assistant sandbox.  We have a
Codelab and try it out yourself
and get your base can project up
and going.  If you are a
developer with us Smart Home and
want to understand more about
report state we have got a
Codelab on that as well.  And we
will be hanging out in the
sandbox after this.  So please
come and talk to us.  Thanks
very much.
(Applause.
)
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  We will be making room
for those who have registered
for the next session.  If you
have registered for the next
session in this room, we ask
that you please clear the room
and return via the registration
line outside.
Thank you
Test test
Build a universal camera app
Thank you all for coming.  Great
to see so many people here.  My
name is Oscar.
and today we're going to speak
about camera.
major topics.  Second snap is
here with us today.going to show
case how they use the camera
APs.
And we will close with how
camera API evolve and the
ecosystem that goes with it.
compromises.  Some are outside
of your control as a developer.
make better decisions where you
have control within your app.
Let's cover how camera works at
the physical level.  As any
photographer knows, it is a
steps at the physical level.
The simple light goes through a
lense
which passes the light on to
millions of light sensors.
Then that converts the light
finally pixels.
When you think of light sensors,
the first thing that comes to
mind is
Now we have Cmoss and APS which
are more
commonly used in today's modern
cameras, phones, et cetera.
as the camera module.
raw picture, a raw frame.
It is not entirely unprocessed,
but it
the camera module at this stage.
You can think of the camera
module as
these frames.
In early hardware, we have three
physical pins for different
kinds of pictures.
days, modern designs, we have a
single pin thanks to tricks like
multiplexing so forth.
But the consensual model remains
as having separate  processing
pipelines kind of image.
We have generally speaking three
broad
recording.  We'll cover those
separately.
The camera module is a black box
T. amount of smarts within.
Some of which are in a close
feedback loop.
with developers will have very
little disability of what goes
on in there.
when you say auto focus or auto
wide balance, the cam practice
module may be optimize those
settings and you don't
really have any control over
that.
all  developers do is send one
configuration in and you get one
frame out.very important.
You send one configuration in
and one frame out.
configuration that goes with it.
To help you with  this, we have
a set configurations.
We'll cover those later as well.
one on.  To as I  said, each
pipeline shown is brilliant use
case.  When it comes to preview,
you can think of it as the view
finder.somebody is holding their
phone up and you want to see
what the camera sees,
we're  talking about.
We need to compromise on some
things.
so many  nings at once.  When
did comes to preview, we.  The
user to be able to see what the
sees much faster.  This is
general results in bare latency
because we're able to compromise
quality.  Some of us compromises
come in the form of reviews.
You may want to enable our users
to capture high quality images.
frame scene figures --
configures in one frame out.  It
may mean you will not be able to
reuse the same raw frame.
you are requesting different
exposure.  So at the physical
level, the sensory different
period of time that.  Means you
will have a different frame
entirely.
necks include exposure time.
Some of them can be processing
power,
number of other things.
blend of the previous two.  We
care about the speed.
have frames come in consivity
isivity isento lutef --
consistently out of the camera.
case we find the right balance.
only test for so many things.
Android runs in Maine devices,
not about low end too.
Unfortunately, we can only test
and say so many things.
tested scenario is when you have
preview pipeline running, plus
one other.
hard time if you want to have
all pipelines running
simultaneously.
the hardware.  We discussed
tradeoffs made by the
now we will dive into the
application layer, what we as
developers can do.
of a frame.
are finally ready for us to use.
Follow the steps, ESABC and it
will fall?  Your lap.
don't believe me, ask Snapchat.
The first decision you have to
make as  the right device out of
the ones available in your list.
Device here means the camera
module.
Each phone may have multiple
cameras.  You probably have this
one front, one back.
especially important now that we
have multi-camera APIs.  You may
have multiple devices that are
back facing that you can choose
from.  So you will have to go
through those
one fits your use case best.
Once you have successfully
opened the
cram device instance and that is
necessary to pursuit forward in
the open camera covac.
the various same covac to
monitor the statua of your
camera device.
may be yanked from you if the
device can
be done.
camera output targets.  This is
where each of the pipelines
your frames in the form of
buffers.  The memory may already
be allocated
get referenced tod underlying
surface andfas as a target.
Otherwise may have to wait for a
callback.
session, which is specific to
the
open can be created.
the camera capture session is
specific
opened earlier.
Once the session is ready, you
can build a capture request.
templates must be used.  If you
don't want to take any of the
template manual for full
control.  Otherwise, the
framework is going to
that closely align to the camera
consensual model we discussed
earlier.
preview and photo and record.
The capture request contains
specific
output target we call frame
configuration inut and input and
out.
surface here and attach it.  It
needs to be one of the surfaces
the session.
This is the configuration part
of it
in the configuration in and out.
have chosen theical practice the
best that we want.
particular device and now we
built a capture request that
will be used in that session.
finally ask for a camera frame.
We send the capture request to
the
We can do this if two ways.  We
can send a request once or we
can request.
This makes more sense in uses
for preview or via record.
configuration for every frame.
This is easier to ask the
framework to continuously repeat
it.
calVic to you want to listen to?
You should look inside of the
capture callback.you want to get
the frame for CPhuh processing,
one of the options is you
have seen image shredder.You can
get whatever picture information
oust the output surface you had
set up.
that into the GPU, a great idea
you is have seen running script
allocations.
choice.
And this is the cycle step 1
through 5 that we need go
through for every single frame.
Recall.  One configuration in,
one frame out
and a bunch of tradeoffs in the
process.
>> All right. Thanks, Oscar.
My name is Mustafa Abrar.
Oscar said about the lower
layers of the camera and sort of
work up to your app that you
make and how they influence how
you interact with the camera.
tradeoffs in terms of
architecture, how to remark
feather the camera framework
app and we'll talk about
specific challenges in sort of a
more narrow use case.
Snapchat, the first thing that
haps is into the camera.  And
the reason for in is that people
use the cram now as a means of
They're taking a picture or
they're  adding metadata,
creativity and then sending it.
really like the cursor where
what do you have to say and
trying to get that out
possible is sort of the thing we
really value.
decisions that we made and these
will the camera.
video, in pictures, front cam
remarks of them are full screen.
Now you typically don't see this
in a lot of cameras.
camera out, picture mode is 3 by
5 aspect ratio and a lot of
timings you
actually optimized for specific
aspect ratios.  So since your
display is usually 16 by
other aspect ratio that might
not be available for picture
mode.  We have to make a
tradeoff. the devices will have
something that matches, but it
might be really high
encode that and create a JPEG
out of it just takes a long
time.
terms of of the resolution we
select for pictures and videos
and so forth.
There's no video mode.
When you have this design
choice, it
leades to a set of optimizations
you
Videos you can tell the system
the user is about to record.
if you don't know the user's
intense, if they long press or
take a picture, know ahead.
So you can't decide upfront what
configurations are always going
to work.to do static
configurations that are good in
a lot of scenarios and we have
and we update those depending on
what the user's intent is.
Snapchat has offered lenses and
features inside of the camera.
motion, your face is moving and
you're
user's face, optical image
stabilization, there's a lot of
things
these things that want to keep
track.  It has a lot of perform
overhead.
need to balance the work that
you do.
You have to current the picture
in
can get their message out as
fast as possible.  Most cameras,
if you take a picture,
latency and it stayses in the
background.  You don't see T.
how long it takes.  But for us
because the real estimate
when users edit the canvassf the
image video.  You have to make
certain tradeoffs to have low
latency to get there.
these and some other features,
you have support and be
university.  There's a few best
practices that I'll share.
sort of help broaden the width
of devices you're able to target
and also those devices.
Over time, you will add
features, lenses, interaction.
that's extensible so you can
plug and play different things.
Oscar mentioned.  The part with
the camera and there's versions.
Camera one and it's been around
for many years.
And then there's also camera
two, a  API.  Although, camera
one is  depredictionated, you
know, when you
users, it's a big chunk that's
still on camera one.  So you
need to support it regardless
the device says.  The second
part is there's different
modes for camera two.
adapt, they have a Legacy mode.
We have made our API work, but
under 1.  And also camera 2
varies by device.  Some say yep.
Camera two works great here, but
in deep down, it is still camera
1.  So the performance you get
might vary across devices.really
need ton each of the different
products that you want to
target.
since 2016 we have written both
camera 1
of code and then what we do is
we add a layer on top that's
basically what our
just unify what it looks like
underneath.
If you have shared coid
full screen that I mentioned can
be shared by both.
So there's shared code, but
Next part is there is millions
of devices.  A lot of them have
bugs and they say certain
feature.  It doesn't work.
You zoom in beyond 99 %, a bug
comes.
that let us decide what
behavior, what configuration to
adopt.
really see and over time, you
have to groom it.  You have to
maintain it.something that's
just code.
I talked about the camera
interaction,
the coat, the code that talks to
the camera  system.
Excuse me it
APC.  If you expose this to your
applications, it is a little bit
too raw.
talk to the cam remarks they can
do  things that sort of conflict
with each other.
life cycling and things you need
to be aware.  We have a queue,
an operation queue
you coa less things that are
redundant and manage sort of
invalid states.
conflicting features by having
an operation queue and a thread
that processes them.
is so everything on your right,
the gray side, is really about
the UI.  You know?
button you see, the auto focus,
the animations, all that and
then it has a okay.  The user
tapped auto focus.  Let's ask
the camera to auto focus.
in inform and tries to drive the
asynchronousd process.  On the
right-hand side and left-hand
have different responsibilities.
Your surface comes in over time.
Oscar was saying.
It starts showing up on your
screen.  You have lenses that
get composited on
of it and this is done in open
GL.
We try to do it sync ronewsly
and not copying anything large.
Your UI is composited on top.
As far as the user is correspond
Tall
reality, it is multiple layers
coming together.  If you look at
this, what you notice left and
the right have sort different
things that you're concerned
about.
it is client server
architecture.  The right-hand
side is like the  client.
side is your run time, your
processing and the concerns are
different.
perspective, the left-hand side
needs
to worry about processing frames
really fast T.worry about
disability and a lot of things.
The right-hand side is about
features, a lot of the candy in
terms of how the user interacts
with the camera.
you ever work with client server
is
Takes hundreds of milliseconds.
Sometimes some issues.
You can use dationer use dagger
and other approaches.
We'll just mock the APIs to the
Android system and maybe do a no
op or send whatever we want to
do.  One place where we take
advantage of it is performance
testing.
example, if you add new UI logic
and you
want to see if it regresses the
cram way, you don't care how
long they take.  If they are
variable and it takes 100 the
cram and it's variable because
it's a system service, then over
time, you
catch ten millisecond
regressions.  What I am showing
here is a start up
So the camera has been mocked
out.
It is starting the app
repeatedly and
how long it takes to get to a
stable point.  We can catch
regressions around
what changed might have caused
it.  Another example, instead of
replacing
can replace part of it.
You can keep other functionality
in tact.video file.
And so this is very useful in
your face tracking.  In the lab
environment where you run
integration tests, there's no
faces.There's no people in the
lab to look at the camera.
video files to drive that
interaction.
of me running some lenses where
the frames have been mocked out
from a video file.  So there's
me.Hello, I/O.
You can seat
see the paper showing.  It
snaps, it takes a picture.
you add new feature and just
test things in isolation.
So this is kind of in terms of
this gives you the performance
considerations on the left.
range supported that have
cameras from front facing rear
and the remote that the
performance considerations in
the UI and extense age.specific
use case.
Snap chat has known that the
media is just images.guys take
photos and how does it all work?
We break it up into several
stages.capturing.  Quickly
capturing the content so that
you can actually process and
allow the be creative.  Once
they add all their creatives,
you
that they have done and
transdeed into something that is
efficient to transport the
recipient.  And the last part is
rendering.  That's the part
where the recipient the content
and depending on the choices you
make can really affect the
quality they see.  All of these
are complicated things and we
have teams dedicate said to each
will touch on the capturing one
for  today.
called, but there's a lot of
latency involved in this step.
camera one, the  API is called
take picture.  It takes 400
milseconds on a really from last
year whereas if you take the
preview frame that's optimized
for low
You can seat see the P90s are
quite high.  We'll optimize as
much as we can our for specific
devices we feel are pretty good
latency and we enable it
remotely devices.  And users are
delighted.  Wow.  The quality
went up.
It looks really cool.today.
People notice it, but they
notice the delay.
will notice it right away.  So
what we do is we try to do a
tradeoff.
and screen shot on certain
devices.  If it takes too long,
we fallback to the screen shot.
tricks to work around this.  You
can see examples here where the
noticeable.  But it is not
always a slam dunk.  In this
case here, take a picture on
causing noise.  Sometimes the
algorithms might overcompensate
and you will see speckling.not
always turn it on.  Certain
front facing cameras we disable
it.conditions.  So we balance
that.
tradeoffs.  Oscar talked about
the low level.
design choices of what you
decided in your application.
The user intent.
picture and it's disappearing
versus is the user preserving
something.
we shared will help you guys
build a better camera app.
Thank you.
everyone.  My name is Vinit
Modi.
platform PM.
Oscar earlier identified a
seriesf tradeoffs to use cram to
APIs.
elaborated on that theme how
they applied those tradeoff in
the real world situations.
and talk about how working
together we
both the developer and the end
user experience.
It's moved on from mere
photography as in immersive
medium.great example of that is
what was
demonstrated in the key note
where the
is now used to do geo
navigation.  In addition,
cameras are everywhere
there's a great example in the
Android things booths, to your
laptops to devices.  And that's
a trend that I want you all to
take away.
are becoming the norm.
Recall the camera model that
Oscar talked about earlier in
the talk.
do you extend that model in a
multi-camera situation.  Let's
walk through an example.device
with three back cameras.
The Native camera app todayha
access eachf these sensors.
In addition, the Native camera
app has something called the
logical camera.This is a virtual
camera.  It's made up of all the
physical sensors.
and it takes care of some of the
tradeoffs that Oscar and Mustafa
alluded
performance and latency.  So in
the native camera app, you
actually have four cameras.
virtual, three physical in a
three camera device.
But as developers, you only get
access them.  This is often
depends on the different types
of devices.
tradeoffs.
You're using the APIs
differently from the Native
camera app.
to announce the starting with
Android P you'll get access to
all the cameras
to all the physical streams.
This applies to both the front
and
different form factors.
The lady in the picture, this is
an image of a (inaudible) mode.
optical  vision, getting
monoChrome more.
But most of all, we're excited
of the
use case us that guys are going
to build.walk through this API
real quick.  The first thing you
told is check the
check if the device, the logical
multi-camera API.
Nyou would check to see which
physical make up this logical
device.
Today, we start support for RGB
and add more.  Here it gets very
interesting when you have a
logical camera that is front and
one back sensor.  Finally, you
would check to see if the
are synchronized.  So I know
what you're thinking.  Great.
New API.  Which devices will
support it?
new API?  The answer is yes.
new devices will support this
new API and we're working with
many partners to
devices also support this API.
So let me call out a few
partners.
the monoChrome sensors are
supported.  They helped us test
this API.
insure that a majority of their
devices support this API as
well.
devices from both WA WA and
(inaudible) support newup graded
devices.Android 1 team.  We have
worked with manufacturers from
worked across all tiers of
Android and
is not just exclusive topo tier.
together we can elevate the
camera experience  working with
you, our  we're really trying to
make sure that we can bring
amazing experiences.
very excited to see what you're
going to build with the new
Aperson Is and
you need make using these APIs.
We'd love to continue the
conversation
space and thank you, Oscar and
Mustafa for sharing their
insights.
Thank you, ask snap
Thank you everyone for attending
and enjoy I/O.
Add transactional capabilities
to
your actions
I am Naomi Makofsky.
assistant on Google.
your typical day, you're buying
coffee,
grossries and paying for dinner
with your families and friends.
about shift towards assistant
and how actions on Google can
help users get things done.
dive into how users can buy
physical
goods and now digital goods
through the assistant.
understand the big picture.
We're at an amazing point of
where users are turning to their
devices to get things done.
goals across the widening
landscape of these  devices.
want to know, I want to go, do,
see, hear understand moments
expecting to get
B or have a dinner reservation
booked for them.  It is not just
their mobile device
ing to in times of need.
They have smart speakers, smart
cars,
evac couples, the technology is
embedded in everyday devices and
accessible more than before.
we discussed through I/O this
week, our approach too this era
of digital
We're  seeing a few things
happening.
than they've ever been before.
devices are far from the call
center
menus of the past or chat box of
yesterday.
to their devices with queries
that are more natural and
querying beyond the key word.
category for things like do I
need an
umbrella today to weather
10011.
for these digital assistants
have become mainstream.  There
is increased familiarity from
members of the household all the
way up to the oldest.  You can
take my parents' house where
father cannot fall asleep with
the can probably imagine.  But
lastly and most importantly, it
comes down to our users.
more curious and more demanding
andmore impatient than ever
before.momentsf need.  Every
time they want to know
something, go somewhere or do
something and so on.
as a result of 3 behavioral
shift, so to have their
expectations.
be more personal.  They want
personalized results just for
them.
me have increased over 60% in
the last two years alone.
realtime.
From brands they want realtime
current events to be entertained
and consoled.  We see this on
social channels today.
they want immediate results and.
To know it can be delivered to
them in
more than that, they want to
know what is open now, what can
be delivered now, even book
tonight at a discount, of
course, and we have seen that
same day
category has increased over 100%
over the last two years.
about the where.  Users want
their brands to be everywhere
they are.
So as we have been developing
the Google  assistant, we
thought a lot
where and the how users are
interacting with Google.  So
when they wake up, they're
asking home what their day looks
like.  When they go home, they
will turn to
directions.  They're searching
on Google.  They're plague games
on their Android devices.fluid
interaction across surfaces,
devices and properties and is it
stems
retrieval to content consumption
through action completion.
areas and we think about how
actions can throughout the day.
How can we streamline their
morning?
they're on the go?  And how to
have a relaxing evening when
they're home.
platform to be truly assistive.
But more than that, the user has
to be
way.
updates, we will talk a little
bit about  today.  Last year, on
a stage very similar to this, we
announced that transactional
were coming soon to the
assistant the DR transactions
API.
ago, we launched it in the
United States.  And now we're
doing this in even more
countries.
live in the UK, France, Germany,
Canada, Australia and Japan and
coming to more course of 2018
and beyond.
the actions on Google platform,
we're
ability for user to purchase a
good,
limits remain the same.  The
dimmer will -- the twiner will
user in account linking and
assist along the way.  We will
break this down a little bit
further.
purchase of a coffee or cycling
class, three transaction types.
First a reservation or
appointment booking.charge or
have a cost associated at the
time of that booking.  The next
two require payments.
the developer can support a
transaction via the users
payment method that's their
business.
We call this bringing your own
payment method.
since you need to know who that
user is
in order to charge their card,
but the use a payment helper
from Google.
So if you want to support a
guest way to get that
information from Google and
we'll talk about this one in a
bit.transaction.
It's a fairly simple slow.  Like
any other transaction on the
able to send them updates
throughout the life cycle of
their order to make sure it is
on top of mine.
Had maybe a few more French
fries than
typical week.  So let's consider
a quick example.
I tell the Assistant they would
like class for Tuesday at 2:00
p.m.  Jay's cycle spot will
confirm this booking.Tuesday at
2:00 p.m.  I say yes and my
booking is complete.
In the app, I get updates and
tell spin class is still in
progress because I haven't quite
made it to that class
where I'm going, what I
purchased and the stage of that
order.
payment is required at that time
of booking.
you're bringing your own payment
method or you're using Google to
help you
First, you want to chick check
that a help you with basic
settings and information to
assist along the way.
where you can check that
transaction
settings are turned on so you
don't get
the flow only to find out it
can't transact.  If you are
shipping a good, you will
delivery address.  So we can
help with that.  When they set
up the assistant, they
information like payment
information, delivery addresses
and so on.
information and should you need
it, we can help by passing you
this information
So if the user hasn't already
entered information like their
delivery address, can also help
you by prompting the user
for the entry and then resuming
the conversation.  Wean the user
wants to transact.
So it is time to start building
that cart.
an order that is flexible and
easy to use.  Libraries can hip
build quickly and way.
You pass this in order and we'll
take care of presenting it to
the user in a
clear and consistent so the user
knows what they're buying and
how much they're paying for it.
off in the  conversion funnel.
very familiar with this.  We
know that it is not about
creating
getting the user through the
point of transaction as easily
as possible.when you bring your
own payment method
or when you use Google pay.
payment method, you are using
cred aspectuals that the user
has on file something like this.
We accept from credit card to
cash on delivery.  It is really
up to you.use the information
you pass us to let the user
everyone exactly how they'll be
paying.will notice that the user
is going to be paying by a card
and it's my gold card to be
exact.
is a display friendly name that
the user is able to see that
matches the payment
previously set up with your
company.  Now, if you choose use
a pilot helper
a bit more information about
your processor.  Users have
already saved hundreds of
casheds to their Google's
account and we can  securely
pass this information to
assistant transaction with the
user's permission.  So you tell
Google who you need to how much
you need to charge them for.
Google then encrypts the raw
credit
processor's key to generate a
credential and passes that
token.
other credit card you have on
your site.
This is part of the Google pay
APoh.
you use Google pay and your
Android app or site.  One  API
that works everywhere.pay
supports the processor's listed
here and we'll have more coming
soon to the platform.
complete at that point of
purchase.
the user will find useful and
follow on actions to help them
with next steps.
API, you can send updates to the
user throughout the life cycle
of the order.
let them know when the order is
received, when it's being
processed or even when it's
complete.Also, you can add
follow on actions.  So this
enables the user to do things
purchase, place the reorder,
contact you.  These are
seamlessly taking quick
post transaction.
progress on enabling transax.
lot of you guys, got your feed
bark what, works what does not
work and that road map.  Thank
you so much for that.
roup dates as we launched
transaction on
more countries, in more Google
platforms.  We also talk about
supporting a lot
transactions and then we'll talk
on my
favorite topic on supporting
digital topics on transaction.
You can start  monetizing
assistant.
huge this year.  It is
continuing to grow.
through the key note and through
all the
I/O sessions that we've had so
far, it's
for us and we'll continue
investing in it.
Starting this week we're
announcing
to transant world wide.
Neigh can buy physical goods and
home, on third party speakers
and the smart screens now
launching in July.
mission to help users accomplish
their task.
beyond the service provider, but
also help our users accomplish
their tasks in
that are convenient and that are
fast.  Throughout my session
today and
will, do you will see that
payment.  We'll keep touching
base on that.journeys.
You have seen in the slide
before.  If you are anything
like me, nothing
First days of the week, that is
nie first  transaction.
solve simple but essential
tasks.
As I walk through few demos, I
will
that are everyday used.  We use
that often.  Also visualize the
opportunities
of these flows.
Another thing I do, I will walk
you through how we
learn through each of these
demos.
.  Hi, Google.
Order my usual from Starbucks.
That's all.
usual  Starbucks?  That sounds
good.45.
But the balance on your
Starbucks card is $1.
30.your card?  Put $20.45.  Are
you ready to place the order?
I put your order in.  It will be
ready soon.  Enjoy.
up my coffee after this session.
something that our users will be
able to do fairly soon in a week
or a few weeks from now.are two
things I want to highlight from
this demo.  The first thing is
personalization.
and remember the experience,
Starbucks knows my name, greeted
me by my name.
It even knew my drink.
or the conversation that you
call it to coffee you want.
Starbucks recommended me a usual
location based on what my
current
where I ordered in the past.  So
don't to have a conversation to
up the coffee.  So (inaudible)
who knows your name and knows
what drink you want when you
walk the local Starbucks, those
are the kinds
of experiences you we want to
build on assistance.
drive user trust, drive useer
delight and loyalty on
assistant.payments piece.  In
the first couple of
conversations,
location I am picking it up at.
For most users, that's it.
Starbucks needs to have a great
coffee waits for you when you
enter the Starbucks.
point that when it comes to
payments, when it comes to
transactions, seemless
But equally important is clear
transparency to the user on what
they
much they are getting charged
for who does the transaction
look like.
experiences, you will see that
resonating.  So just to
summarize.
world wide this week.  The
devices we support are Google
smart screens when they launch.
We are already live in the U.S.
up  UK, Canada, Germany, France,
Japan and Australia.
does it mean for me?  Do I have
is to start from scratch?
I have to build the whole
experience again?  What the cost
of doing this is?
launch a new surface, do I have
to build my actions again?  The
short answer is no change.
already had an action that was
using transactions, working on
phones, it will for the Google
home devices too.  For the smart
screens too when it launches.
needed on the outside to light
up new surfaces.  We do the
heavy lifting to make sure
crossed all surfaces.  Sometimes
as eye developer, you might
vice-versaus when users on a
screen.  And that's fine too.
You can actually build those  we
support T.
the  underlying mechanismsf
those transactions remains the
same.have to change.
If you don't have an assistant
yet, you have double the ranch
to go and build one.You get
every new surface free with any
of these transactions.
when you bring your own
transaction method.
When you use Google Pay, there
is no
to light up the transaction on
the Voice surfaces.  There are
two other things I will talk
which I think were in the demo.
The first thing is built and
intense.
We launched built and intense.
When a user says order me a
coffee or
me a coffee, this is how aivity
isant knows -- assistant knows
which action can fulfill one
intent.To ask what we use for
matching and ranking.
to sign up for the right
intents.
The second piece I will
highlight is the conversation
design.
Use dialect to create great
conversations.  It is very
important to have your of the
conversation.
Make sure you use the brand
tonality.
you, they should know that it is
your brand that they are having
a conversation with.
building blocks, I talk about
quite a few of them.important
ones is account linking.
If a user starts on phone, we
will
over to phone to account link.
And the drop offs for is very,
very high.number.
We have a 90% plus drop off and
the user over from the home
device over to account linking.
starting a  developer review for
account linking over Voice.
What that means is users can
sign in
into an existing account using
Voice.
screen or a phone.
A user can create a full new
account in Excel over Voice
without having to go to any
other  surface.
in to an sifting surface, they
will sign in to when they come
to any Voice devices.right?  I
will talk go how it works as
well.forward.  You ask the user
for sign in.consent.  Once the
consent is there, we share with
you a Google token which has a
lot about the user.
Think of the user's Gmail
address and additional
information.
user, you can link that okayf
account and -- that account and
create the
We will use that token for
future use.  If you do not find
that user, you can user with
information that we give you and
send us the token.
saw earlier can come down as low
as zero
with some of these experiences.
I think I will walk you through
some some of what the APIs look
like.console, there's a separate
setting you have to sign up for.
different surfaces and what
experiences you want to build
for.
speaks for itself.  Can for sign
in.  So when you ask for sign
in, we prompt
the flow.  Value token is the
most important piece.  So when
permission -- when the user
the permission, we shared all of
this
information with the user.
We send you the name, the given
name, the last name, and much
more.
your side if you want to.
the beautiful experiences, let's
talk about more things.Here is
the summary of building blocks
experience.  The Voice
experience we talked about.
Built and intense.
a lot more implicit traffic.
Personalization like needless to
say
user trust.  Conversation
designs and then the Voice
transactions.
are visiting us from all
different parts of the world, we
are  eaching up in
Spain, Italy and India too.  And
know we're adding more
marketings
A lot of exciting stuff
happening on Voice.  I.  Sure
you guys will want to see what
look like.  We will share the
link towards another talk where
you can go and see all of lot
more detail.  But let's continue
through our journey.  We talked
about the (inaudible) chain.
Let's talk about users on the
go.  She has a coffee in her
hand.the go.
surfaces there on search,
they're on more.
And we want to provide a
consistent experience to our
users when they move to another.
Why should the experience be any
painful on any Googlesur face --
Google surface.
are bringing them across all
surfaces.  I mean identity which
is the Google
about, payments, receipts and a
lot more helpers like delivery
addresses and locations and so
on.
So these are now able cross
multiple surfaces.  Let's me
show you guys a quick demo on
in search and we'll go into more
details on that.
tasks and we talked about the
coffee, the essential tasks
which is getting
movie tickets:  So movies near
me, A
breaking -- avengers is break
every record out there.  Fine
dango offer fast checkout.
that.  So the fandango
experience on what we have build
is all on app.
all about how to deliver
content fast.
Now they're bring transactions
into AMP.transactional
experiences will get very fast.
I am showing all production.
You will see they're very much
what our users see when we take
it live.
select two tickets.  Next.
General admission.  Sounds good
to me.  Next.
the payment information.A a
user, you don't have to give any
Obviously none of this is shared
with fandango till the
transaction is done.
Complete with chase.  And the
transaction goes through.
booked for me for today evening.
And the other thing with this is
if
screen, there is a my order
experience where I can go and
find and track and I
So if I want to find where this
is, I have to look for the
tickets and a
place where any user can go and
get the information.
They can ask assistant what time
is
and assist ant will answer the
question.  It looks like I am
not fandango customer.
to lose the points I get on
buying movie tickets.  This
share and sign in.  Looks good.
And will this is account
linking.  I have account created
on fandango
I will go in and try to get
fandango tickets.  It is all
linked through my Google
profile.
So that's the demo I had for
fandango.  Our users can do so
much coming in for and other
things.
The beauty is users get a fast
check out because of these
experiences.
are what we call convenience
optimized.  Users almost never
have to fill out a show you a
much more complicated experience
in a (inaudible).
track all their receipts.
Excuse me from a merchant's
perspective, you have full
control over the UI.
create differential experiences
for your users.
the customer coming to your
website, a visitor coming to
your  app.a loyal customer.  So
I think that's one big value
from this  experience.
higher conversion rates.
With Google Pay, we have two
partners.
conversion rates going back
20%.
So that's a big lift for a lot
of partners and developers.
merchants spend less time
planning and let's you focus on
what makes sense for your
business.I showed for fandango,
you will see
something like that coming soon
with it as well.big.
One of
my favity activities -- favorite
activities.
When you order food, food
ordering includes nuances.
restaurant, menus are like 10
pages long.  There's menu
browsing and customization.
as a user, you want something
glutin free, I want extra
spicey, I want what not.  After
you have what you want to order
figured out, then is it is
delivery I want to deliver at
this time.
I want delivered in a window of
3 to fire.
3 clocks
the door and you can leave the
food at the door.order.
You want to know realtime where
the dasher is.  You want that
experience to be fast should
just work out of the box.  Let's
look what doordash experience
looks like.quick video.
Order delivery from companyina
venty with doordash.
This is the menu browsing piece
I was talking about.  This is
the customization.
using AMP.  Add to order.  So
let's add a dessert too.  They
have good desserts by the way.
are down the street.  So check
out the saint thing with the
payment selected.on the file.
And you can do the transaction
place order or replaced.
experience for our users.  Even
without signing in can actually
complete transactions.
multiple different entry points.
ordering and so on.
So let's talk about useers last
piece
customer journey which is have a
relaxing evening at home.  Today
we're announcing (inaudible)
that means is our users can now
buy digital goods on assistant.
on phones and on order Voice
devices.  U.S.
seven markets we talked about
earlier.
So it's been a tiring day and
tirey
and when you go back to your
hotel or to your room or house
based on where you
I prefer meditating.  So let me
walk you through an experience.
Is this is basic session, free
package from headspace.little
bit.  10 minutes two days in a
row.  And that's all headspace
offers are free.
subscribe to headspace now.
Yes.  Makes sense.
Three products headspace offers
are
annual and $400 lifetime.  I'm
cheap.  So I will stick with the
$12 monthly package.
So here is a proposed order.
Remember when I talked about you
have
what product they're buying,
what credit card is being used
and what the price point is.
to propose that before they
subscribe.  Transaction is done.
You are on your way.sent to you.
You have this experience
enabled.  Now, the beauty of the
solution is
consume the digital goods across
surfaces.
If a user bought something on
the
they can access that digital
good on assist ants.
If a user buys something using
this on  they are able to access
the same experience on Android
too.
how they jump different devices
across
assistant and Google surfaces,
the
experiences they have seamlessly
flow.  From a developer's
perspective,
is assistant play integration.
If you are a developer who saves
up transactions on assist ant
too.  You are using play
console.
and so on.
High developer looks something
like this.  You can now sell the
experience to the user.
the squeu.  If yes, you can
deliver that to the user.not,
you call the Google APIs and we
tell you what the squeus can you
sell to
any filtering criteria that you
might have.  You propose the
order with the product The user
confirms yes.  We process that
transaction and we
is a transaction confirmation.
Here is a purchase token and you
on to the user.  So this is a
great opportunity for our
developers to monetize.and
experiences.  So for example,
the headspace experience was
premier experiences.
space, a lot of you guys might
be aware of coins or extra lives
and extra turns.whatever you can
sell from a gaming perspective
works beautiful in this
experience.
cart digital media purchases
like
renteddal like rentals and so
on.
digital goods, they're opening
up to sell on all assistant
surfaces.
few months since we have
launched, so developed brands.
Enable that user wherever they
are.
You can buy your pizza from
dominoes
pretty soon you'll be able to
get your
favorite Starbucks coffee from
the Assistant as well.
continue additional
functionality, we're so excited
to see what you developed for
what we can all build together.
Thank you so much for  joining
us on
hope to see you next year.
[APPLAUSE]
Sound amplifier and the new
Dynamics
Processing Effect
everybody.  My name is Brian
Kemler.
I
Ricardo Garcia.
last day of I/O?
Last session?  Woo-hoo.for
coming out.  It was a great I/O.
Today we have a lot of really
exciting things to talk about.
Primarily geared for developers.
We're going to be talking about
a few
Android P called sound
amplifier.  We're going to be
doing a little bit
we can improve the sound in any
type of situation for users and
how you can do developer.
We're going to go and do a deep
dive into the inner  workings of
sound
the Dynamics Processing Effect
upon which its built live with
code examples.really cool.
Let's dive right in.
empty field with a massive set
of ears.
is we live, work and play with
an increasing amount of
environmental noise.
sound is one of the most common
environmental problems.
It's not only annoying, but it
from understanding our friends,
colleagues and loved ones.
No matter how well we can hear,
most
us can relate to the following
acoustically challenging
situations.
date in a loud restaurant or a
loud bar.  Trying to listen to a
caller in a
Trying to listen to a speaker
who's
talking way too softly like me
now.
environmental noise as a form of
situational disability.
just your Smartphone so you
nevermis a word in a
conversation?
introducing sound amplifier
What is sound amplifier?
Sound amplifier is a new
accessibility
on real world conversations
using only
your Android Smartphone and a
set of headphones.
tune to hundreds of personalized
levels
to optimize their listening
experience
It's two sliders for loudness
and tuning.
Dynamically adjust over 100
audio in the background.  These
settings can be applied
independently to each ear.
the sound quality in an after
ray of
situations -- an array of
situations.
somebody who speaks too softly,
turning up the TV volume to one
that's
the room without blasting
everybody else.
So now I'm going to go in and
talk a
we built it the APIs and the
effect upon
which it was built and I'll do
some demos.
is base on Android P's
processing effect.
The effect is a 4-stage signal
and I'm going to walk you
through each
stage and then Ricardo will come
in a
deep dive into this and show the
developers in the audience how
they can applications.
Stage 1 is pre-equalization.
You can think of
pre-equalization as
that you can programmatically
adjust any raidio frequency.
Think base, mid-range and
treble.
Stage 2 is a multi-ban
compressor.
The multi-ban  compressor is the
heart dynamics processing
effect.  What it does is really
unique.
really loud or irfating sounds.
Don't worry.  I won't make any.
are too soft.  It can do all of
this without changing the
characteristics of the
underlying that you put into the
system.
The third stage is also an
allows to you fine tune the
outfut from
the original MBC and
pre-equalizer and
What happened the limiter does
is protects users from
additional gain or
volume above a certain developer
designated thresh hold so that
there are
little demo.  So I'm going to
play a very typical
micro kitchen water cooler type
of break
where there's a loud espressor
maker in I'm in this.  I star in
this.
So I can adjust this and start
to hear the conversation.
this is customizable or tuneable
for every user.  Doing this
again.  I get to star again.
really not this into myself.
Here's my talking kind of
rehearsing this talk right now.
speaking to quietly.  So this
will be another example of how
hear it better.
The other thing they also forgot
to mink was use this with your
headphones can think of what's
in the video as what you would
be hearing in your  headphones.
under the best circumstances in
a quiet
background noise and a large set
of ears.
>> But in noisy conditions, the
everyday reality is that we
work, play,
So listening is difficult.
any acoustic situation to the
forth and Ricardo is going to
deep dive in and talk a little
bit more about the
effect and how developers can
start using this today.
Well, now we saw the demos and
we saw
actually working in real life.
So we are going to go down and
see how
what is the magic behind it.
to you the hearing treasure.
I will explain to you what is
here.  Here we are seeing what
is the for the average human.
The hearing threshold is
actually how
to lease into the sound.
So in this plot, we can see from
left
high frequencies from 20 Hertz
to (inaudible).  We see how much
energy we actually the sounds.
So because this is the
(inaudible) of
below that thresh hold will not
be heard by people.  So for
example, if we go and we look
We see that the thresh hold is
lower in there and we need less
energy and a sounds that can be
fainter and softer and we will
hear them.
level in around 100 Hertz.
You will not be able to hear
that.
companies use this kind of
hearing treasure to design their
equipment.
MP3 owe CD players, they are
present.
O you are tuning a headset,
speakers, these are really
important to know what people
will actually hear and what they
are sensitive to.
So we can have hearing thresh
hold shifts due to so many
circumstances.Let's say the
noise in the environment.  A
minute ago, we have the AC
blasting a thresh hold shift.
We needed to have sounds that
were way
to listen to hear the sounds.
When they see (inaudible) a
minute ago
softer and we can hear that our
thresh hold shifted down at that
moment.
a region that will need more
energy for
you to be able to notice that.
We have other shifts.
can have shifts that are not as
broad ban, not all over the
spectrum.
localized.
This is snowing us a shift --
this is showingist a shift
around 500 Hertz.
some noise or some obstruction
that is
not going to allow you to hear
things around 500 Hertz.
These shifts can be permanent.
Or it can be temporary T.
can be a temporary situation
disability.
That means for that period of
time, you are not going to be
able to hear things
around those
not working well, your ears are
not
Sounds below that thresh hold,
the shifted thresh hold, you're
not going to that.  That's the
important take away from this.
If it's below the thresh hold,
you cannot hear.
of interest?  Let's say you are
listening to music
someone is speaking or some
sound that interest you?
and has energy all over the
place, but if you notice again
around  500 Hertz, a that is
below the thresh hold, the
shifted thresh hold, the blue
one is going to be lost.
have a sound of interest that is
below the thresh hold, the
shifted thresh
difficult to be heard or the
(inaudible) is really bad.  You
cannot understand the sound.is
the question that everybody is
asking.  How can sound amplifier
help us right now?that you ask.
Sound amplifier is going to take
the sounds and is going to
actually boost you need them the
most.  If we look again in the
range from 500
sounds and the new process
sound.  We took the sounds that
were really
much energy and we boosted them
all the way over the shifted
thresh hold.  So now we can hear
those.
We took the sounds that were
already loud and we moved them
up but not too up.
So the loud sounds got  louder
but not too loud.  So if you see
the process that
it was not uniformed all over
the spectrum.  It was shifting
things and trying to over our
shifted treasure.  So it was
doing a very intelligent boost
in there.
are done by the processing
effect that we introduce in
Android P.
in a minute.  I promise.
As Brian mentioned, it's the new
The pre-Q, post Q and what we
are using this effect, we have
two big questions especially for
your sound amplifier.  First is
what kind of processing we
sounds to be able to depending
on the needs that we have.
connection or in an airport or
depending
what kind of processing we need
to make shifted thresh hold that
we have.  And the second is how
users can
the right parameters they need
for you.  So we have two big
questions to answer.
the processing what kind of
processing we want.  What Google
is really good at we took
and we start crunching that
data.
So we took data from hearing
treasures
impaired oozier and we put them
in there.
noise obstruction
in the lender and we went to --
tried to get the other content
from the other
A conversation, movies, music,
live concerts, lectures.
together and come up with a set
of recipes.
So parameters that will be good
for sound in many situations.
When you do that, you end up
with -- I
a bunch of solutions that are
pretty much parameters, very
complex parameters the dynamics
of the processor.  For this
situation, this will be good to
shift the sound. situation, it
will be that.
But that is unimagine
unimaginage.
parameters and it will be very
difficult for the users to make
something good with this.
took a step and did some
dimension reduction.
dementional space and flattened
them out.
In here in the right, can see
that we
those is kind of a formula or
processing
recipe that we want to fit the
dine amin
to change the sound and with the
dimensional functionality, we
sound two major (inaudible).tone
and the boost.  The users -- so
this solves the second question
that we have.ares are going to
navigate this?  Well, they don't
need is to know all the
parameters that we need.
We give them two sliders that we
saw in the demo and by moving
those sliders,
doing a very Intel gem mapping
and going
and moving a thousand parameter
-- not a hundreds of parameters
in there.
When the user goes and iterate
using
actually going through a bunch
of recipes, a bunch of
processings and they
suits them the best at that
moment for the user in that
location.  Has what we wanted to
do.
that was kind of like a bird eye
view of how the sound amplifier
works.start talking about code.
What can you do with the
dynamics processing effects.
the processing effect as a new
library Android library
processing effect.
talking about use cases.  So
when can you use a design amices
processing effect?
You can do a sound amplifier.
You go there because this is now
Android P available preview.
You can go tonight.
amplifier.  Win that, we are
expecting people is
to create their own sound
amplifiers or
to be able to hear and listen
better.  Another example,
another month that
have a device, an Android device
and you want to tune the
speakers or headphones,
will equalize or do something to
the headphones to make them
sound flattered, base, something
that you want.  Now with this
effect, it will be easy
(inaudible) to do that.  Another
application that is really
interesting is the TV remote.You
are watching TV  2:00 a.m.  You
can't sleep, but if you start
sometimes someone is whispering
in the movie and immediately,
music comes in there.
really loud and you woke up
everybody in the house.  You can
actually have something that
whisper, the very soft part of
the movie can be raised up, but
the loud part or happening in
the movie can bring down and
everything will have a more
level sound in there.
example can be for media
players.  You are doing your own
media player
some (inaudible) mastering.  I
want to listen to classical
music in a train.  You would
like to have the control to be
able to again squeeze the loud
sounds
up the soft sounds so everything
is
working well for the range you
have in there.
I promise (inaudible) is coming.
power with this effect.  The
architecture that we show
before, we were kind of lying.
little bit more complex.  The
architecture yes.  We have four
stages.
but we can do more things in
there.  Inside of each one of
those stages, we  that you can
control.
We have the bands and in the
pre-Q
have as many bands as you want
and you
can control each one of those
bands.
limiter, but you can also
control that.
All of these it comes into a
channel.
going to have channels here and
you can
can index all of those and say I
want to change the multi-ban
controller in the to change
this.
We are giving you an API to do
all the of nose things.
you notice is the limiters.  The
limiters are linked limiters.
is important when you are
talking about both channels to
be able to change all if you
need.  Yes.  We promised code.
We have some code.
dynamics processing effect.
For this, we decide because we
have so d to have a config
builder.So you create config
builder and then (inaudible)
effect.
First with a config builder in
this
example, we can have some
parameters the variant, the
(inaudible) of channels.  We
will talk more about that and
then
disable each one of the stages.
In this example, yes.  We want
to use pre-Qand limiter.99 of
bands.
We can say how many bands we
want per stage type.
have 8 bands.
The multi-band compressor 10
bands and the (inaudible).
stage types needs to have the
same number of bands.that you
want.  We have extra parameters
as I mentioned.  The variant and
the number of channels
the set prefer from the duration
that you can set in the config
builder.
are actually creating a
configuration.  We are saying
build and we have a
configuration object.
configuration directly.
Sometimes I want to finish the
of my effect and go and change
the  default parameters.  In
this example, I am getting a
a channel act on the first line
and I'm  saying from channel
number 0 in this
multi-ban compressor.
And then I iterate through the 8
multi-bans that I have and I
went and  the parameters in each
one of them.  This is an example
for I/O.
I am sure you canmore things.
We can set the ones that we
want.  The release, the talk,
the ratio, the that you want for
each ones.
Finally, we go and instance here
the dynamics process
can (inaudible) with the config
file that we just created and
the session ID.
this effect to whatever media
player and
those that are of interest for
and you control everything.I'm
going to ins-- instead of going
on the API just  showing the
right code, I
more metato show this in
graphics a little bit.
are running realtime, we can
have access just show you.  And
we have many channels.  So the
channel we can index the
So 0, 1, 2, 3.
Each channel object actually has
some parameters like the input
gain that you go and change on
the channel or you have the
stages.
You can access the pre-Q
multi-brand  or limiter.
And let's say at this moment in
AQ, you can grab the AQ and look
exactly the the  API level.
API view point and change
parameters or change the
parameters in each one of bans
there.  Sorry.  It is going very
deeper.
We can go from ban to the EQ,
from the collection of channels.
So we have access to all the
(inaudible) we want there.for
the multi-ban  compressor.  We
can access it inside of the
channel
parameters that we have in each
one of the bans.
And lastly, the limiter.
Now I will dive a little bit
more on each stage type and what
are the
(inaudible) and getters that we
have there.  First the
equalizer.
with the equalizer.
When an equalizer, we will
specify different frequencies
bans.
0 to 500 Hertz, 500 to 3,000,
3,000 to 7,000 and we are going
to change the
gain that we have in each one of
those bans.
In here, we can is the the bands
any
So we can have many bans and
current frequencies that we.
This graph is mislieding because
all bans are the same width.
That's not true.  You can do any
wealth that you want.
up the bans, you can go and with
what we have here, we can get
the gain, what is set the gain.
We can change all of these also
real  time.
We are going to then the
You are only showing one ban in
the multi-ban compressor.
ban, but this is -- this is easy
to show
what the multi-ban completionor
does.we have mentioned, when you
have a compressor, a multi-ban
compressor, the
that are really lewd and main
them softer and sounds that are
very soft and make them louder.
way we have here, we have the
same sentence in the before.
medium and soft in the top.
After we apply the processing of
the
to look like the after that is
the loud sound is a little bit
softer, the medium the soft one
goes very loud.
The way that a multi-ban
compressor
second.  We have the inputs what
is the level
from minus 100 to 10.
The lower the number like
louder, a louder sound.  And the
compressor what is doing is
the input is above the thresh
hold, we have a thresh hold
parameter is going to know,
that's too loud.  I will bring
you down.  But if it happens to
be below the touched.
In this graph, it is minus 40.
The input was minus 40 level.
We are below the thresh hold.
We are not going to modify that
signal.
So if I choose a value of minus
20,
Let's choose an input of minus
10.  That's better.
the output.  That means that the
sound became softer just because
it was above the thresh hold.
With all this parameters with
the compression ratio, thresh
hold and the
output gain and other
parameters, we are able to do
what we have been promising.
take sounds and make them
louder, but take loud sounds and
make them  softer.
multi-band compressor is  doing
and it's doing this in different
bands.
frequency from 0 to 1,000 Hertz
and behave in a different way
that the
will behave.
We are giving you all that power
to control.
of the most complex ones, you
can get this.
attack time, release time,
ratio, all these parameters that
you need configure
do this per bands.  There is one
thing and I'm sure that
everybody is asking this.
pre-game, a post-game.
If you have a multibrand
compressor.  It is true.
pretty much the same.  We talked
to developers and people
life and some -- a big portion
of them really like to have an
equalization and
multiband compressor to do some
tuning of microphones and
speakers.
So the easiest way for them to
make
some some redundancy and do the
API in
such a way they can pour all of
this  into.
It is the same the multiband
And what this is doing is pretty
much the same.  It's taking a
sound and if it's way
it's above certain levels, it is
going to squash that down.
found at the end of any all of
your processing chain.  You
don't.
and the sound is really loud and
you don't they want loud sound
to come out of the speakers.you
go and the limiter is going to
say sorry.  This is too  loud.
will squash it down.  It doesn't
destroy the speakers.  So it is
really good.myself something
about the link.  The limitsers
are linked limit or and we have
the link group.
When we have multiple channels,
say we have two channels.
channel something really loud
happened in that channel, very,
very loud.
only the left channel.  The
stereo will shift all the way to
nothing.  But if they ever
linked and for some reason one
of the channels got a loud
both will come down
simultaneously and
the stereo silling
stereo signal will not move.
able to control them in a
multichannel environment, let's
say you want to link
the surround  speakers in a
different group so you can keep
your spacial image in tact.that
was another feature that was
asked for us to do.
Some more comments about the
dynamics  effect.  The real time
controls.  All the the controls
that I tried to
very big, I will encourage to
you go in API documentation.
All the controls most of them
are  controls.  You can use them
and once your affect
that you want.  You can change
levels in here.  You can changed
attack, the  release, ratio,
anything that you want this any
of the channels in any of the
bans.
much the same API for instance,
sometimes you want to create an
effect
immediately as soon as it starts
playing.  It is playing with all
the parameters.like that.  We
also have some implementations.
At this moment, we are offering
two
We call favor frequency and
favor time.  Sometimes for this
effects, if you
frequency as main
implementation, it is
good because you can have very
precise
need 84 your algorithm and at
the same time, we are giving the
desired frame size.can give to
all your engine to the
effect engine to say I like
frequency
forever your processing.
into AOSB.  So all Android P,
AOSB is shifting with this
effect.effect.
If an OEM wants to come with
that implementation, they are
encouraged to do that.talk to me
afterwards, but yes.  Go ahead
and do this and the only
with this.  Very good quality
effects.
The were the thing is this
effect is  as an insert effect.
You can go and implement it in
your application.music
application.  You just go and
use the Android media
and all the effects and
processing and it will be
available for in the
implementation.
We learnd a bunch ever  things.
We learned a new feature.
amplifier.
It uses only the Smartphone and
set of headphones.
cool demos and thank you for the
sound people that turned off the
AC at that things a little bit
better.  We learned about the
hearing thresh
shifts and how these power the
way that
the sound amplifier works.
dynamics processs effect.  The
code of how the stages work and
dynamics processing effect.  So
with that, we want to give
thanks
involved in this project.
Brian, the accessibility team,
my
team at Google, the sound
understanding
team, our team in TAIPEI that
helped
anticipation you saw today and I
want to help you for staying on
the last day of I/O. us if you
have any  questions.  Thank you.